[Musique]
salut
à tous vous allez bien
[Musique]
ça commence à faire
on est paré maintenant
et donc voilà comme je disais hier ça
fait très plaisir de te de t'avoir aussi
parmi aux invités sur tscom
sera là avec nous et demain aussi
également il me semble exactement c'est
ça donc voilà qu'aujourd'hui on a deux
matchs palpitant à suivre le premier
c'est la demi-finale des perdants qui va
affronter Jules Moussard à Fabienne
ocarwana donc Fabien qui a éliminé hier
l'autre français Ali resa donc Jul aura
beaucoup à faire pour essayer de passer
en finale des perdants donc la finale
des peradans on a déjà
c'est le perdant de la finale des
gagnants
on a deux tableaux si vous voyez un à
gauche et enfin en haut en bas donc le
premier tableau et ben c'est
donc du coup il est en finale tout à
droite à grande finale vous voyez et en
fait dès qu'on perd un match et ben on
est relégué vers la poule des pervers
donc après ça dépend le grade si on peut
au premier tour même si on est relié au
premier tour et ainsi de suite et on
voit que votre forest c'est l'a perdu
mais au dernier tour donc on va demain
il est au dernier tour voyez hein des
des perdants et donc pour être éliminé
de la condition il faut perdre 2 matchs
donc pour l'instant off qui a tout gagné
il a zéro défaite en terme de match on a
car wanna qui a une seule défaillère son
compteur contre d'ailleurs
qui va compter maintenant Jules qui lui
aussi a une défaite à son compteur
contre un premier tour donc les deux
joueurs vont s'affronter pour une place
en finale déperdante contre vent de
Forest et le gagnant de la demi-finale
et du joueur qui est en finale
affronteraf pour la grande finale et ce
qui est marrant c'est que du coup si par
exemple imaginons je dis au hasard je
nul venez à arriver en finale contre
contre le joueur Roosevelt et ben ce qui
se passerait en fait c'est que Jules
devra gagner deux matchs pour venir à
bout d'Abdou
parce que si par exemple enfin tous les
gens qui sont en bas ont déjà parlé un
match donc en fait
il y a une prime pour le gars qui qui
arrivait invaincu à la fin quoi ouais en
fait si absent par exemple je contrôle
Jules pour la finale si il gagne le 7
baisse terminé je leur ai pas entendu
deuxième match donc qualifié donc perdu
par contre si bas dans le match et ben
ils ont tous une défaite donc il y a une
deuxième vie comme tout le monde bah oui
sinon c'est pas c'est pas cool quoi
jusqu'au bout ah non mais toi tu as pas
le droit de perdre
et donc dans les questions passées on
avait le cas comme ça c'était Caravana
qui était arrivé en finale en battant
tout le monde et
Naka qui est remontée qui a battent tout
le monde et qui arrivent en finale
contre karwana et qu'il a battu deux
fois
donc donc Nakamura qui qui était éliminé
je crois aux deux ou troisièmes tour qui
a quand même gagné l'événement face à
carwana donc là on a un tableau encore
assez ouvert il y a quand même pas mal
de possibilités et il y a encore un
français en Corse donc c'est Jules donc
on va un petit peu ce que ça va donner
et les parties qui devraient commencer
dans un instant je vais voir si
sinon j'ai toujours pas moi chez moi ça
va pas commencer c'est quelque chose un
petit retard dans le début de deux
tournois donc on va voir un petit peu
quand est-ce que ça commence alors je
vais remettre la scène avec les avec les
joueurs
et les joueurs qui sont même pas
installés donc c'est pas commencé ils
sont pas là ça c'est clair
et
donc au niveau des pronostics
c'est vrai que
quand même sur le papier favori ça fait
depuis des années des années qu'il est
top
dans le top 5 mondial Jules il est tout
nouveau un et un après un jeu rempli il
est dangereux d'ailleurs j'ai perdu mon
Blitz donc bon possible mais ça va être
que Carolin il est toujours enfin il est
en tout cas ici favori hier je me disait
pendant une interview enfin quand il est
venu sur le sur la chaîne que ça allait
être très difficile et qu'il fallait
qu'il soit très bien préparé parce que
tu as vu un caronat il est à la
redoutable quoi et
de toute façon on le connaît c'est un
joueur de l'élite depuis déjà d'une
dizaine d'années et il est bien connu
pour ses prépas alors après ici je sais
pas à quel point il va lâcher des gros
trucs je crois pas mais même en jouant
ce qui considère que mettre le 2 ou 3e
choix ça restera quelque chose de très
bon quoi
c'est ça c'est ça donc
en tout cas en tout cas c'est c'est
hyper cool moi j'aime enfin cette
affiche elle est cool on avait vu on a
reçu Jules pendant les trois premiers
jours et Jules il a perdu le premier
match contre app the off et il a dit
qu'il espérait pouvoir battre ses
shimanov enfin qu'il a affronté dans le
premier match des perdants et il aimait
enfin il voulait vraiment le battre pour
pouvoir derrière affronter un gros quoi
je voulais jouer en gros bon au final il
a joué il a jouécolar ce qui est un gros
mais en moins gros que un petit gros
quoi
il est pas plus gros que Jules quoi oui
voilà ils ont un joueur qui a à peu près
son niveau alors qu'il aurait pu jouer
un film
et donc la cadence elle est écrite sur
le stream c'est 15 + 3 donc on va avoir
on va avoir deux parties donc en
aller-retour et en cas d'égalité et ben
on aura droit à un armage et donc
surenchères donc ça c'est assez marrant
parce que bon ça psychologique parce que
ça dépend vraiment à quel niveau tu veux
vraiment les blancs ou les Noirs donc tu
peux exagérer un petit peu on avait vu
sur vous déjà qui avait au Collard 5 il
avait mis 8 minutes pour avoir à tout
prix les noirs et au final il s'est fait
rouler dessus avec les Noirs donc
difficile un petit peu à dire mais en
tout cas c'est intéressant
ouais bon en fait je crois que
à très haut niveau c'est mieux qu'ils
aient noir ils sont tellement bien
préparés et que c'est facile après dès
que c'est en dessous je crois que c'est
mieux de prendre les blancs et le temps
quoi
ouais ouais en fait après ça dépend
aussi de de comment va le match Julien
d'expliquer qu'avec les blancs ils sont
massacrés habituellement et du coup il
voulait il a il a pris les blancs il a
mis quasiment 11 minutes il a marqué sur
les enchères il a mis 11 minutes
ça me va mais sinon et ben j'ai les
blancs quoi et du coup il a eu les
blancs contre 9 minutes et quelques et
en fait
il a pas du tout fait le poids connard
et de tout quoi
donc
ouais
j'ai vu cette disponible ouverte et
voilà
il y a pas eu trop de suspense
ouais non oui ben il y avait un DK qui
pouvait avoir lieu tout le temps qui a
été joué un petit peu tard au final
et non mais Jules en fait il a bah
c'était plus facilement quoi
c'est protégé en plus non c'était
c'était assez dur pour
pour que l'argent puisque lorsqu'ils
auprès de déconnexion non mais j'ai vu
mais bon
pendant la partie ah déjà avant ok c'est
un peu mais en fait apparemment c'était
pas la seule partie c'était d'autres
parties avant et tu es pas serein était
tu peux être aussi un peu énervé et pas
jouer ton jeu quoi hein
tu étais quoi
ça peut te déranger clairement donc bon
salut à tous alors vous préférez quel
côté alors nous on est on est pour Jules
on est pour la France bien entendu
tu penses qu'il parle de côté blanc haut
ou en bas ou je sais pas quoi bah on va
mettre Jul en maths mais en fait j'ai
pas compris
j'extrapole enfin je suis pas sûr
d'avoir compris ta question mais
mais
voilà en tout cas bonjour à tous donc je
vous rappelle qu'on a quand même une
minute de décalage par rapport à par
rapport à vos commentaires c'est pour ça
que des fois si vous parlez et ben on en
est calé c'est pas qu'on voit pas vous
répondre c'est que des fois on est juste
un peu en décalé donc n'hésitez pas en
tout cas à nous écrire et si vous avez
question ou des ou des choses
particulières à nous dire n'hésitez pas
en tout cas
à nous on vous lira on vous lira et on
vous sera de vous répondre voilà on
essaiera
la pertinence du Commentaire la question
non ça y est on va on va essayer de vous
répondre
pas encore commencé hein je t'avais dit
il y a toujours un peu de retard donc
qui donne 17 heures mais la partie elle
a pas commencé là je vois rien du tout
c'est actualisé mais ça ne marche pas
sans Caroline n'est pas encore installé
il est devant il regarde
de famille ça doit pas ok il a un truc
dans le chasseur ah oui tu vois pas sur
le stream tu as une de quel âge tu
regardes le stream tu vas voir il est
debout et tu vas voir un grand chaise
tour écrit sur son pull et le grand
gesto qui rend de ce jeu d'ailleurs je
pense que Kévin Kevin
qui qui nous fait un grand un grand
Blitz Carlson qui qui a commencé avec un
6 sur 6 non
il fait je sais qu'il a éliminé à 7 sur
7 à un moment il a fait une nulle et
puis il est reparti sur 4 ou 5 victoires
d'affilée donc en fait là il est défonce
tous c'est quand il est quand il est en
forme il lui signalétable
en fait oui mais il était tellement pas
en forme enfin quand il est arrivé au
rapide c'était laborieux bon il a perdu
la première bon ok ça peut arriver
qu'une
il en gagne aucune le premier jour et il
en gagnait aucune le jour 2 et tu vois
enfin il finit bon je crois qu'il y a
plus un mais en battant genre des
hatchschenko quoi et aucun top joueur
et puis arrive le Blitz et puis je sais
pas c'est trois petits jours de
d'échauffement là ça n'a ça a mis en
jambe et puis là d'un coup la machine à
claque est parti quoi
gagner le tournant mais je crois que là
il a deux points d'avance quelle
commande de la fin donc à priori a
priori il va gagner il est pas mal mais
après ouais
pas terminé
oui non mais en fait pour gagner ce
match je lui il doit être à son meilleur
niveau déjà ça c'est clair et enfin bon
match tu peux pas un Caravana en faisant
un petit match normalement car voilà il
faut le sortir quand même donc Jules va
devoir puis cawana il s'est mis à jouer
pas mal en fait ces trucs sur Internet
oui non mais il a complètement changé à
l'époque c'était le client quoi bah en
fait il respecte pas trop le truc donc
je pense qu'il s'entraînait pas du tout
et les jouets bah juste bon enfin ok on
lui dit de jouer c'est quand même pas
mal d'argent en jeu dis bon bah ok je
clique mais sans trop chercher et là en
fait il joue vraiment un bon niveau
quand même ouais bah il gagne tout quoi
le temps en avant mais il a gagné là il
a pour l'instant il est pas mal
et puis écoute
il est là il a gagné dernier Manchester
à plus cast ouais puis même en rapides
c'était un peu le client il avait 28
quasiment 50 en l'an et 2700
c'est à dire que donc après par client
on s'entend mais un joueur aller numéro
2 ou 3 mondial peut pas d'un coup être
numéro 20 mondial en glycéride c'est
retour de niveau baisse quoi et mais là
ouais il a fait les efforts et bon en
tout cas sur Internet c'est grandement
amélioré
[Musique]
et donc ouais enfin oui
impressionné c'est qu'il avait battu ml
c'est un
speechestre et en fait il a battu sur
tout ambulette alors
c'est complètement rasé en fait par
voilà et
le but
non pas prévu bon après c'est du Bullet
mais c'est du une plus une donc en fait
quand même tu as quand même ça a
commencé je vois que les joueurs
regardent quelque chose chez moi j'ai
rien
je vais essayer de voir
tellement de truc là ça commence
Jules quand même avec les Noirs je vous
mets du côté de jus donc c'est une
pétrole donc très solide à part de Jules
salut
bah écoute ouais la pétrole c'est une
désouverture la plus solide possible
et bon le truc c'est que on a connait
bien évidemment bon enfin pas que la
pétrole mais la pétrole ça a été son
ouverture principale pendant pendant un
an ou deux il avait gagné des candidats
grâce à ça il l'avait joué exclusivement
ça dans le match contre Magnus en 2018
et en fait après il a arrêté de la jouer
mais sans avoir perdu pour autant
tu vois des fois tu changes l'ouverture
parce que
parce que ça te va plus parce que tu
commences à être à perdre dessus ou je
sais pas quoi mais là ça devait être
juste soit par les études soit pour voir
autre chose mais en tout cas elle a
toujours été très bon résultat avec un
côté noir oui il y avait donc c'était de
beaucoup par Fabiano mais aussi par les
Chinois on avait des Chinois qui
s'étaient mis aussi à jouer à jouer la
pétrole exactement et puis bah du coup
ça peut être des émules maintenant il y
a des pots il y a de Bouddha
mets un peu de jouer c'était un peu
moins étonnant ouais non
très solide et ce bon ben il aime bien
quand ça quand c'est ça bouge pas quoi
[Musique]
isolé voilà après c'est contre la
structure avec C6 c'est pas la même
quand le pion est aussi
dans ces histoires ça change de trois
trucs ça change que justement il y a de
la pression sur la diagonale A2f enfin
de G8 muscle B5 qui va chasser ce fou
mais c'est quelque chose surprendre en
compte et aussi je dois dire que je
crois qu'avec les Noirs c'est beaucoup
plus dur d'avoir des chances à long
terme de gains qu'on peut pion isoler
parce que
en général donc en plus on sait
si tu changes toutes les pièces légères
tu joues qu'avec les pièces lourdes et
que tu triples sur des blancs tripes sur
des tu me laisses 5 et pour gagner le
pion à cause des cloises et la seule
manière d'éviter pour les blancs serait
de faire F4 pour pas qu'il y a 5 mais du
coup ça te fait de toute façon des
flèches pour le roi
etc il y a genre une vieille partie de
cauchemaricarpov au championnat du monde
marche plus c'est 78 ou 80 mais ou Carpo
fait bien gagner là-dessus et là le truc
imagine qu'il y a que les pièces lourdes
en fait il suffit que les Blancs fassent
B4 pour pas qu'ils c'est 5 mais c'est
beaucoup moins compromettant quoi bien
sûr parce que je veux dire c'est que
même dans le cas de figure le pire pour
les blancs ou tu as plus une seule pièce
légère et que tu as plus que tu as
faiblesse en D4 alors ok témoins bien
mais c'est plus symbolique que qu'autre
chose bien plus dur de d'ouvrir avec ces
cinq une fois que tu auras triplé sur la
colonne des pour gagner le pion des
parce que bah en fait c'est plus facile
de de jeux B4 qui empêcher ses 5 plutôt
que de jouer F4 pour empêcher 5 6 le
pion était là quoi ouais en gros c'est
ça le truc donc
côté blanc tu vois c'est un peu isolé
donc il faut avoir ses faiblesses mais
normalement il est pas très risqué qu'en
général OK
et si ton médecin alors B5 ça peut
visuellement être un peu moche parce que
Ben bon on se met un peu en arrière en
C6
et puis ben plus tard on imagine que les
blancs vont pouvoir réagir avec du A4 et
cette casser un peu la structure et
gagner aussi des cases puis c'est vrai
que le pion c'est 6 devient un peu
faible ouais
non mais bon déjà j'imagine qu'il
connaît en fait je trouve qu'il joue
vite tu vois enfin s'il faut décider ça
après mieux réflexion c'est pas facile
je pense donc bon et de deux je crois
qu'en fait de toute façon pour
développer les pièces c'était pas
évident sans B5 à cause de ce qu'elle
est B8 qui est pas de case le cavaler de
venir ici et donc du coup B5 ça sa
logique avec le setup choisi juste bon
bah comme on connaît pas je peux pas te
dire à quel point c'est bon pas mais
j'imagine qu'il va revenir vers ces 7 et
vers des cinq
c'est quand même de bloquer de base le
bouton isolé pour après l'attaquer
avec B5 on va on a quand même chassé le
fou C4 de la diagonale et de ce fait on
arrive à contrôler un peu mieux la case
des 5 et éventuellement peut-être mettre
un fou en moi je pensais
F5
non non mais je vais être gagnant
peut-être mais la position elle est pas
mal bon après il y a quand même du KFC 3
il faut voir le centre game fragile tu
vois je baisse quand même
mais clairement B5 ça inconvénients donc
voilà mais bon c'est sûr que dans sa
préparation en tout cas je l'ai vu Jules
avant de faire dépenser 4 ici
il a mis un peu de temps à réfléchir là
j'ai vu et il a
par terre
genre réfléchissais et d'un coup il a
fait genre oui et il a fait genre ça
enfin tempo ça et ça en fait il s'est
préparé hier dans le dans le stream il
est venu sur le chat il nous a dit qu'il
fallait vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de
carvana et je pense qu'il était en train
de réviser un peu ces variantes tout ça
et donc là il est il est en tout cas
c'est cool parce qu'on voit qu'il a
l'air quand même dans plus ou moins
enfin l'impression qu'il voulait et car
voilà qui va juste essayer de chèque une
partie normale
donc voilà en troisième partie qui est
intéressante parce que on joue contre un
pion isolé on a chacun un petit peu un
problème de structure
et c'est une position qui qui joue quoi
juste ouais bon au moins déjà
ouais c'est ça enfin c'est pas fait
attraper dans l'ouverture quoi alors
pourquoi à 3 après une idée avec ouais
l'idée si on peut passer par B4 enlever
le foot des trois et aller vers des cinq
ou même faire des des petits trucs pour
Noël cavalier 4 et aller en C2 faire des
fourchettes ou des fousser deux pour
faire de la dame par exemple bah déjà
[Musique]
si je prends la lame bon tu as un
problème sur sur un enfilade et donc
internet il faut que tu manges en F5
mais je mange de la dame en F5 si tu
manges là-bas toujours l'enfilade
même si je réfléchis simple mais bon il
y a des trucs comme ça et surtout on
prend peut-être que là on peut se dire
qu'on a quand même réussi un bon notre
mission avec
un bloqué ces gens-là c'est un peu comme
une carrocane en position
donc bon ok avoir
mais dans l'idée en fait c'est que je
passe mon tour après Caval et B4 faut
bouge et ben je peux avoir des idées
même comme du Fou aussi pour moi même
manger à deux peut-être c'était une idée
et puis comme tu l'as dit il y a du café
de fourchette qui peut arriver des fois
c'est Dame s'en va et quand même je suis
content quand même pas mal de cases donc
pas de dangereux et à trois malheur
quand même assez normal pour empêcher
camer les B4 toutes les expansions qu'on
puisse avoir à la dame
en gros à trois c'était vraiment juste
pour contrôler B4 du coup donc il est
fou j'ai 6 bon peut-être il y avait
d'autres coupes aussi mais pourquoi pas
et qui avaler H4 il vient s'en prendre
au fou et donc il menace donc de gagner
une pièce en fou et les miner le
défenseur du cavalier et de manger
probablement l'une ou l'autre je sais
pas laquelle alors en fait ouais c'est
vrai que généralement on préfère plutôt
faire celle-là pour ne pas
enfermer la Tour Eiffel et généralement
quand tu fais tu auras études c'est que
tu as envie de faire 50 tout à l'heure
je parlais de mon idée je voulais
complètement fou F5 c'est pour ça que là
j'aimais bien les Guiers de tour à 8
pour que les deux tours mais il est vrai
que la Tour Eiffel peut-être que
peut-être que c'est pas terrible moi je
mettrais plutôt
[Musique]
parce qu'on pensait c'est logique en
fait je pense que tu veux jouer avec F5
tu peux jouer à 8 mais si tu peux pas
pousser le Pione en fait juste ça aucun
sens c'est toujours tout refait et bien
sûr tous le champion isolé donc ça reste
très très logique je te bouffer le coup
et je prends voilà donc paire de fou
pour les noirs pour les blancs pardon et
puis bon on attend ce petit plan de
cavalier qui va finir en dessin et à
quel une position un petit peu où on
peut éventuellement attaquer on a un fou
qui est marqué sur le sur le roi en
cavalier aussi la dame a un petit peu
éloignée
bon je vois pas comment on peut comment
on peut
mais en tout cas bon c'est une potion
qui joue à la part de vous c'est un peu
déséquilibré
ouais donc bon
en tout cas renforcer mais bon ok la
dame c'est probablement pas con mais en
fait
mais
voilà soit tu joues pour pour casser la
structure soit toujours pour jouer en
fait d'enfant et tu as fait une chanson
et jouer sur le plan arrière donc et
puis on prend ça quand même la
souffrance aussi
c'est si tu es vite par je sais pas toi
aussi trois bouches ou quoi peut-être
j'ai déjà 4
ouais c'est important
que ça tombe bien d'avoir ce truc parce
que bon en plus ça permettrait de jouer
le cavalier contre le mauvais fou des
blancs et que d'un coup les marques
peut-être même mieux quoi bah si jamais
j'arriverai donc c'est
l'apprenti que tu vois dans la
quarantaine où j'arrive en fait mode
pépion là et peut-être un Cavaillon C4
quoi ça c'est terrible
non mais du coup voyons ça je pencherai
sur dame prend ces trois toutes bêtes je
voulais prendre deux B pour regarder
madame
mais si je menace rien bah c'est
complètement
donc
il y a pas frangin 6 en tout cas voilà
non est-ce que j'ai trois mais bon j'ai
trois je crois qu'elle va les 5 en fait
j'arrive à j'arrive à temps j'ai trois
j'ai attends attends attends
essayez de faire ranger 6 du coup sur
cavalier 5 ouais peut-être fou des deux
je pense que je rêve un petit peu
d'avoir en tête les tactiques et même si
elle marche pas maintenant de savoir
quel thème peut-être un moment d'un coup
ça sera mais là ça pourrait enfin
vous pouvez le faire là je vois pas de
réfute non plus direct quoi
[Musique]
malheureusement j'ai qu'à aller prendre
ici et là il y a plus il faut prendre H2
échec parce que bah et puis on range les
trois donc
un bon pion là et bon je prends là et je
prends là donc là je gagne mais si je
mets le four en D2 et que je menace
c'est pas ma joie un coup sur passer mon
tour
cette honneur de jeu pardon donc passe
mon tour et ben en fait maintenant
menace en fait tu en prends des cinq
avais pas vu tomber pour Chloé je t'en
prie
on est content
mais
du coup est-ce que les blancs à 4
maintenant ou autre chose de toute façon
mais
qui me semble logique
alors à 4 oui
casser la structure on a envie de punir
le B5 joué par par Jules et donc en
jouant à 4 en plus je m'attaque là il y
a un visa ici un vis-à-vis là
et on se demande comment il va réussir à
sauver
à peut-être faire qui essaie 7 mais
disons après après embêter ses promesses
peut-être tu auras cinq ou un truc comme
ça faut pas que les Noirs
bon je préfère les blancs quoi
et puis bon bah écoute depuis on reste
quand même une si même si tu vois
toujours un peu transformé un peu passé
mais tu as le droit d'être fuite comme
milieu un petit peu le champ de bataille
le fou des fois tu peux le replacer en
F1 G2 donc tu enlèves la tour à 8 et
puis enfin je sais pas tu as plein j'ai
un point tu peux jouer longtemps sur
position à triturer un peu les Noirs
quoi F5 on va essayer d'éviter Cyril
luxe
F5 c'est assez moche ton roi il est
complètement
vissé sur la colonne F et pour finir sur
la case électrique qui pourra plus
jamais revenir et tu envoies hyper en
danger hein
F5 non tu veux faire F4 mais je partirai
en fait c'est très affaiblissant et
c'est toi qui va être un problème plutôt
que moi je peux pas jouer F5 c'est
beaucoup trop puissant donc dans la
partie Est ce qu'on a dit il y a eu à 4
qui était logique et c'est 7 prises
qui permet de doubler aussi sur la
Colona donc bah écoute
j'aime beaucoup les blancs ici
il est mieux après bon c'est pas gagné
non plus mais voilà le problème c'est
que tu as aucune égalité facile avec les
noirs et ça peut durer longtemps donc à
tours peut-être juste par chacun parce
qu'en fait on a quand même un
dans cette position qui est difficile on
a un bon point c'est quand même que le
pion C3 est un pion qui est arriéré on
peut peut-être éventuellement un jour
essayer de mettre la pression un peu
dessus imaginons je prends un exemple
comme ça peut-être le dame 6 qui
pourrait échanger les dames et me
permettre de gagner la cassation pour
mon cavalier et de mettre la pression
sur 3 donc je sais que le pion il écrit
cette première mais si je peux me venger
sur
par exemple et ben c'est pas tout à fait
clair
exactement toi du coup pas trop de sens
je pense parce que
facile à défendre mais
qui a plusieurs utilités ça bloque le
foot des 6
c'est pas là aussi de mettre le petit
fou en G2 et prendre le contrôle de la
belle diagonale blanche il y a quand
même super diagonale
et en plus peut-être parfois faire h4h5
ou je sais pas quoi
bon à voir donc
et même tu vois H4 de toute façon il
peut le faire ça mangera pas trop de
pain faudra juste regarder
et en plus si un jour on fait même C4
pour changer ce pion Irak contre
l'option B et la tour à 5 qui pourrait
repartir de l'autre côté quoi
quand tu mets le fou par semaine en F3
mais Orange 5 à 14
tu peux aussi attaquer de ce côté là
quoi en fait le problème de la position
j'ai l'impression c'est qu'on trouve
beaucoup beaucoup de moyens de jeux pour
les blancs c'est extrêmement facile à
jouer et il y a beaucoup d'options alors
que chez Jules c'est plus concret il
faut vraiment trouver quelque chose
d'immé diat
je trouve qu'il y a moins de
possibilités en fait c'est moins riche
non mais clairement c'est plus bah faut
résister quoi il faut résister espérer
que ça se trompe en face et que
peut-être ça sourit après
salut François salut à toi
tu vas bien François je pense que tu
connais François Alain
il m'écrit
il m'écrit quand Saint-Père non
[Rires]
mais très sympa français
on verra ce qu'on pourra faire mais on a
toujours un peu la même équipe quoi
j'ai pas pu me préparer comme j'aurais
voulu à l'avance
c'est pas grave on fera ce qu'on peut
bah de toute façon il faut faire ce
qu'on peut et puis
et puis moi je m'arrête d'un oeil très
intéressant tu sais que nous avec Cannes
on est monté en Top 16 mais bravo
c'était pas une poule facile ah non
c'était très
chauds qui ont pas pu
donc on a fait avec qu'on avait on avait
une bonne équipe
qui aurait pu être encore mieux c'est ça
normalement je suis pas là enfin déjà
j'étais même pas remplaçant j'étais
j'avais pas du tout le classement pour
jouer et bon on devait avoir on devait
avoir la bataille et un autre indien
donc 5-50 quoi et il y a deux joueurs de
moi quoi donc
j'étais là quoi
mais bon match par deux bon match et ex
c'est 2 2 un gros morceau c'était les
deux gros matchs de la saison
et donc voilà c'était cool on est
content de l'avoir fait en plus avec
notre équipe en fait parce qu'on avait
vraiment l'équipe avec que des joueurs
du club quoi tu as 100% un canard
et ça fait plaisir quoi
en suivant la
résultat de loin quoi
et ben bravo donc
une équipe après qui est capable de se
maintenir quoi
et vous avez encore des indiens ou quoi
devant et avec tous les bons joueurs
français nous on pensait que que le
maintien en Top 16 pourrait être plus
facile que le la montante
ça peut après bon ça dépend les années
genre l'an dernier vous auriez aucun
problème mais là en fait ça devient pas
mauvais stop ouais j'ai l'impression que
toutes les équipes qui étaient censés
être pas si forte ça
par exemple
chaque année depuis des années
maintenant
et puis non c'est il y a des bonnes des
bonnes équipes bon en tout cas on va
voir nous on est très content de ne pas
participer puis on verra l'équipe qu'on
a moi je sais pas trop courant encore il
y a un an hein bah oui oui mais
donc oui donc ce fameux Top 16 qui
devient de plus en plus fort après je
sais pas si toutes les équipes auront
rend les moyens de leurs ambitions sur
le long terme parce que bon ça coûte
quand même aussi
mais bon mais bon c'est après la Ligue
la plus la plus forte au monde je crois
que c'est bien l'Allemagne je pense en
Allemagne on va l'équipe de
Baden Baden qui affiche le top 10 chaque
match
[Musique]
il y a Maxime il y a rognan
il y a énormément de puis bah même mon
équipe
bon bah moi je suis devenu le 50e
remplaçant quoi
c'est costaud quoi
maintenant il y a dudat
rouge
tu es encore dans l'équipe quoi
et moi c'est un club j'ai commencé à
jouer pour eux en 2008 on était en
troisième division et donc on est monté
machin mais ouais j'ai vu une sacrée
évolution et là c'est plus pareil quoi
ah oui là ça y est en Allemagne les
clubs c'est
ultra fort
je crois que c'est la Ligue la plus
forte du monde franchement c'est très
costaud en plus la règle qui fait tu
peux jouer sans aucun allemand en France
on a quand même ce truc professionnel on
va dire ou tu dois jouer avec avec 4
joueurs français et une joueuse dont tu
as le droit qu'à trois joueurs étrangers
en Allemagne en fait tu peux mettre oui
puisque tu veux
et donc tu fais comme battle ou quoi et
comme nous en fait quand voilà enfin moi
j'aime bien quand même le fait de
pouvoir protéger un peu ben les joueurs
nationaux quoi
[Musique]
pour nous c'est plus simple après ouais
c'était histoire de la fin je sais pas
mais l'arrêt Bosman dans le foot ça fait
avant c'était pareil dans tous les
sports et puis à partir de 93 95
ils t'ont dit ouais mais en fait c'est
c'est un travail donc il y a la libre
circulation des travailleurs sur le sol
européen etc etc et la règle est passée
dans le sport alors aux échecs on s'en
est on
fait ça mais je vois je dirais un club
un jour qui qui débarque qui te met qui
te met 8 8 espagnol pas sûr que
légalement tu es trop le droit de leur
dire en fait t'as pas loin
mais bon personne l'a encore fait et
puis tout le monde tout le monde fait
avec la règle en place et puis bah nous
en tant que joueur français ça nous ça
nous va bien quand même
mais je sais pas tu vois ben oui bon
après
oui mais
je trouve que c'est normal quand même
mais ah mais il y a la logique mais
après il y a des lois et puis
c'est normal
donc bien sûr qu'on est payé dans ces
dans ces grandes divisions c'est les
joueurs en fait les joueurs font
professionnels c'est leur travail c'est
leur travail et ils vont pas t'imagine
comment tu casses le marché c'était en
2007 qui vient chez gratos
tu fais pas trop quoi
plus ils sont rémunérés en général après
il y en a qui sont plus fan négociateur
que d'autres mais
on voit la
[Musique]
on n'a pas très envie non plus mais bon
de toute façon qu'est-ce qu'on a envie
de quoi en fait parce que je peux
comprendre ton ami c'est sinon il allait
à l'arrache 5
comprend tout reprend et on laisse faire
attaquer donc
[Musique]
pour prendre et peut-être même ramener
la tour ici et avoir une belle
exactement
j'ai 5 tours C8
oui bon enfin voilà enfin le concept sur
le même c'est toujours mieux pour les
blancs mais faut travailler pour gagner
mais en tout cas
ça prend forme entre guillemets quoi
enfin c'est l'avantage est plus notable
maintenant qui a qui a du coup
ça reste possible parce que tu vois en
fait c'est ce qu'il a voulu faire il a
il s'était cassis
veut c'est sur ces trois un moment donné
mais clairement les blancs sont beaucoup
mieux mais il faut encore terminé pour
C1 ok donc son pion et peut-être il veut
faire ces quatre aussi pour se
débarrasser de la faiblesse probablement
espérer
il va falloir faire un truc comme ça et
puis ça a l'air pas faim pas facile on
pratique non non
[Musique]
il faut être bien précis
et il faut jouer il faut essayer de
faire des choses
en fait il y a dur c'est c'est de se
décider entre à quel moment faire ça
parce que là tu peux encore avoir espoir
te dire ok je tiens s'il veut gagner
assis si tu dois faire faux F4 français
7 par exemple le reposer
etc donc on peut dire peut-être tomber
si ce prochain coup ben je fais cavalier
5 quoi là c'est une version un peu mieux
parce que je fais fin ici
la question c'est peut-être qu'il y a
quatre quoi comme tu l'as proposé et
peut-être que j'arrive en retard quoi
c'est sûrement l'idée de Fabiano d'avoir
joué Torcéen au-delà de défendre le pion
c'est d'avoir ces quatre possibles donc
pour troquer le pion c'est faible qu'on
ne B5 et si les blancs j'oubliais 4 à ce
moment là tu feras C5 toi-même avec les
Blancs et à ceux qui ont passé protégé
et pour les parler fous quoi
c'est pas un joueur qui qui aime se
faire
visser quoi c'est un peu quand même vert
un moment donné quand dit-on que qui se
fait trop visser il va tenter s'activer
de venir au bureau même simplifier un
pion une qualité mais il va vouloir
c'est activé
donc vous décidez donc n'empêche quand
vous pouvez F4
on va peut-être le C4 ou pas enfin
peut-être de toute façon il y a d'autres
coups pour les blancs s'ils veulent mais
ces quatre a priori c'est une idée quoi
parce qu'en plus on a pas de cloche sur
la tour faut pas oublier les défendu par
le fougère
pas trop d'idées mais c'est pas le chat
derrière
je sais pas genre trop bouge pas trop à
deux pour essayer hein
c'est chaud c'est vraiment dur
il y a un petit point d'interrogation
[Musique]
peut-être que B4 est bien enfin je sais
pas trop mais c'est une bonne tête pour
les blancs dans tous les cas de figure
de toute façon jusqu'en on regarde
prise tout reprend et sur ton C4
maintenant quelle est l'idée parce que
là on est quand même en souffrance
je vais sur le clouage qu'est-ce qui
peut faire d'autre en fait là bon on
peut pas gagner tout de suite de toute
façon
un petit tour
attaque le fou
il se met en place en fait il y a un peu
trop de faiblesse c'est dur
comment tu les prends le fou déjà
je peux briller mon cavalier aussi mais
je perdrai celui-là
c'est la même mais en plus ma structure
elle m'aide pas quoi puis encore la
paire de tout il y a encore
tu vois
[Musique]
mais bon après peut-être tu prends du
pion et tu pousses comme un flou et que
je sais pas mais il a tenté
avec peu de temps la pendule
mais
c'est vrai que bon
[Musique]
mais je pousse le mien quoi
maintenant
on voit qu'il est en bleu turquoise
voilà très bon coup
et la tête Fulla à l'air pas mal
tu prends un G7 et au pire des cas tu
voudras un fou en E4 sur B1 un jour j'ai
même pas sûr qu'on aura le faire
peut-être même aller bloquée ou je sais
pas mais si on prend tous les pions
noirs à la place tu as même je pense
tomber 7 qui va être pas mal parce qu'en
fait
t'en fous contrôle B8 donc attends
là
les torcer un ok bon
tant qu'à faire si on a ça autant garder
une tour pour les blancs
pour la qualité c'est terminé en fait
mais je pense mieux de garder la Tour
Blanche en fait
pour voir s'il y a pas un petit maths
[Musique]
en fait
ça redevient dur
après après
carvana il a quand même une expérience
un peu de ouf sur sur la pétrole avec
les blancs et les Noirs donc
c'est vrai que c'est
je peux comprendre quoi
ok ok bah écoute ça fait 1-0 pour pour
caravane ouais donc là
bon a priori il va jouer 4 et Fabi
est-ce qu'il va nous sortir la pétrole à
son tour normalement il fait plus trop
je vois plus un 4 5 normal genre en
Italie quoi
mais il pourrait enfin dire normalement
le pétrole surtout quand tu as besoin
que de faire nul avec Léna
tu peux la sortir
bon en tout cas en tout cas on va voir
un vu hier encore contre contre Colars
il a perdu la première partie et après
il a gagné la partie pour accéder au
au Armageddon et il a gagné l'Armageddon
donc ok bon c'est pas là maintenant
c'est plus connard ça c'est carvana
maintenant et si gagne celle-là il y en
Armageddon et puis après l'Armageddon
c'est plein de choses donc en tout cas
avoir comment ça va se passer
je propose Fab construire une petite
pause parce qu'on a beaucoup beaucoup de
pub
on a plein de sponsors en fait
prochainement on est obligé de vous
mettre
on se retrouve dans combien de temps
tout de suite
[Musique]
et nous sommes de retour pour la
deuxième partie qui vient de commencer
donc là une victoire de Jules est
impérative pour rester dans le tournoi
donc ça c'est une Espagnole je vais vous
montrer un petit peu ce qui s'est passé
je vous le montre en accéléré
pour que vous puissiez suivre un petit
peu donc l'espagnol assez standard ici
quand
hop des 6 et on joue le plan simple qui
est très typique dans l'espagnol et dans
l'italienne ce plan de cavalier 2 qui va
venir en G3
voilà D4 et ça c'est ok
donc soit tu ramènes le camion C6 mais
les blancs de faire des singes soit de
faire dames et 7 soit tu peux faire
cailler des 7 pour défendre
et tu peux aussi juste échanger en D4
bah c'est probablement ce qui va choisir
donc c'est une structure
où tu aimerais bien que là en fait en
parlant que des pions mais le truc c'est
qu'en ayant fait ses échanges je suis
quand même bien activé la tour 8 elle
joue sur E4 le fou va venir en B7
etc donc si les blancs le temps de tout
mettre en place genre tu fais qu'il y a
eu trois qui est des 5 et F5 je sais pas
quoi bah t'es beaucoup mieux mais bon
les échecs c'est aussi une histoire de
tempo et souvent un une pression sur
très souvent le Pione si on décège au
final
et j'ai une question alors je sais pas
si je mélange un peu les les
positions alors moi je connais pas trop
l'espagnol ni rien que les noirs
et Caval C6 qui existe
alors c'est pas ici je sais pas ça je
ferai des 5 étapes pas la case de 5
ouais il y avait une ligne comme ça avec
un cavalier
et tu en as une autre
avec des fou B7 etc qui ressemblent à
des Belloni en fait ouais ça ressemble
une benne ici
c'est pas la bonne position
et au pire si les blancs font à quatre
même un moment ils vont se gagner la
casse-c4
au final
donc ok ok
alors donc prise voilà un G6 très
logique qui permet d'empêcher qui avait
une bondir en F5 et de mettre le fou
[__]
c'est un coup hyper thématique dans
l'espagnol
donc ok bon après cette position elle
reste quand même un peu mieux pour les
blancs bien sûr mais bon
toute façon je pense Jules peut être
content de la sortie de l'ouverture
parce que c'est une partie qui joue
pareil il s'est pas fait sécher
et donc
notre choix dans ce cas de figure quoi
alors comment est-ce qu'on peut jouer
ici est-ce que alors
je vais te demander si on allait pas
jouer un petit H3 pour mettre le four en
E3 et c'est D2 un truc comme ça ou sinon
naturellement
intuitivement on va dire pour reprendre
la case C4 aux cavaliers mettre le fond
en B2 etc mais franchement tu as des
malades dire si c'est mieux ou pas
vis-à-vis direct
quand tu connais pas la pause
[Musique]
d'un côté c'est vrai que B3 ça aussi la
particularité avec ses quatre
donc je sais pas enfin tous les deux ma
foi ça va pas être mal
on garde un œil sur le cavalier A5 on
peut toujours faire pousser trois on a
tellement envie d'aller sur cette
diagonale quoi qu'il en soit quoi qu'il
en soit pardon et donc et donc pourquoi
pas
ouais qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait jouer ici
que les Noirs
mais je me demandais si après un coup
comme
ug7 peut-être que fou BK prenait un peu
de sens aussi alors je sais pas si c'est
bien ou pas mais je me dis tiens le fou
il part peut-être que la case des 6
maintenant est pas en profiter peut-être
je suis pas sûr mais tu te [__] des
self juste
ouais pourquoi pas
moi en tout cas
il fait des coups naturels Fabienne
[Musique]
assez facilement il y a plein de cases
quand même au centre qui sont contrôlés
par ces pions par ces pièces
c'est un peu le point faible dans cette
variante mais
on voit qu'il a des moyens de
s'améliorer quoi il est pas complètement
bloqué et à l'agonie c'est ça
salut Marius salut personne
bienvenue à vous
[Musique]
hola amigos
j'essaye un peu
sauf que c'est un vrai espagnol bon moi
je sais qui s'est marié
là c'est un peu la ola je pense
[Rires]
sur le a et puis l'accent c'est un
accent tonique il va en haut de sens
normalement il est dans l'autre sens
provoquer
avoir un petit F3
de jouer parce que Dame des deux on peut
profiter du cavalier C4 peut-être qui
pourrait être une bonne idée ça me C1
bah en fait chaque coup de dames
un inconvénient d'un bien bon c'est très
moche on va pas en parler Dame des trois
bah écoute j'ai même du cavalier C4
backlight 5 en fait je peux tout le
temps essayer de m'améliorer en même
temps sur la dame
donc là
la question c'est est-ce que vraiment
c'est mauvais à quel point en fait ça
peut être mauvais avec enfin il vous
donne
pas choqué non du tout
parce que mais peut-être qu'avec le fou
ça diagonale là peut-être que son idée
c'est dans plus tard donc là on va être
le foulard je sais pas si on 17 on va
remettre à la maison mais qui sera un
jour sur 15 noir avec un cavalier H5
enfin je pensais H5 H4 ouais bah un peu
comment
tu as plein de comme ça mais en gros
comment dire en fait j'étais hyper
critique moi du F3 je passe te souviens
du match entre nepo et Edding en fait
c'était ça mais avec elle je crois
oui non H3 et hyper pourri quoi enfin tu
peux pas mais là c'est quand même pas
pareil
[Musique]
en fait
généralement quand tu as une position on
choisit parce que là par exemple juste
pour vous faire un petit dessin là j'ai
envie de mettre mon fond d'écran
pour être empêcher les caves G4 qui sont
embêtant donc là pour empêcher G4
souvent j'ai deux coups j'ai H3 ou F3 et
pour pouvoir en fait empêcher et dire
j'avoue je fais ça je fais ça et
d'ailleurs je crois
qui est un coup bah hyper normal et même
dans tous les positions de sicilienne
même pas plein de positions de manière
générale toujours H3 projet x 3
et en fait ce qu'avant c'est que c'est
cool son peuvent être considérés des
fois comme des affaiblissement parce que
Ben
j'ouvre enfin je bouge un pion du roi
etc d'un côté bon en signe case de fuite
pour mon roi mais en fait je me suis dit
qu'il y avait G4 même des clouages des
fois où c'est qu'on a trouvé un
cavaluation qui peut être possible mais
ce qui est important de dire c'est que
on peut pas jouer H3 et F3 en même temps
ça c'est généralement pas conseillé
pourquoi parce que quand je fais H3
UF 3 mais ce qui se passe c'est que lui
il est plus défendu donc ça peut être
problématique et surtout maintenant on
voit que toutes les cases noires autour
du roi sont toutes hyper faibles
et donc ben là un plan noir hyper simple
j'ai envie de dire H5 H4 je te vire et
une fois que je te vire ben je marque
cavalais là je mets un foulage mais une
dame là et on voit que très très vite
également sont hyper ouvertes sur mon
roi et que je me prends une attaque de
maths donc j'ai mis ce plan là mais
j'aurais pu mettre plein d'autres plans
mais les cases noires en tout cas vont
être ouvertes et vont moins de faible
donc on peut pas se permettre de jouer
H3 et F3 le groupe qui vont pas ensemble
dans une position bien sûr si sur case
noire vous êtes maître et que
l'adversaire en face il a rien Boké on
peut des fois il peut y avoir des des
nuances droits ici ou là mais voilà
vaut mieux pas
donc Dame des trois ouais et qu'est-ce
que je donne ok
j'imagine bien défendre des 6 et
15 pour le cavalier si c'est 4 en fait
il fait un coup de développement je
pense que puis j'ai l'impression au
centre toujours
simple je pense
même très souvent quand il y a un joueur
qui joue un truc bizarre et ben nous on
a envie de réfuter enfin un truc bizarre
alors que des fois la réflexion c'est de
jouer des coups normaux quoi des coups
du coup
on pourrait même aller en Russie
peut-être maintenant la question à se
poser
mais peut-être que ce qui veut juste
rien et te dire que c'est à quel point
c'est plus dur de défendre des 6
jours c'est CB4 pour manger B2 attention
à cette place là pour l'instant je mange
ces quatre pour l'instant j'ai fout des
cadres enfin attention aussi à jardiner
à l'avenir
mais bon pour bien ici à la répartition
on sort la dernière pièce qu'on a pas
encore développée
et voilà non je crois
tout le monde aura bien sorti ses pièces
on met la tour sur une colonne qui vise
une faiblesse
toujours un petit avantage et
voilà
c'est 3 pour venir
taper sur la diagonale
rapide donc il faut quand même si je le
fais il faut être sûr
qu'on va exercer parce que si c'est pour
faire un de ces trois parties c'était
pas génial
OK
ouais c'est simple normal
et comment je peux compter
pour l'instant c'est les cours un peu
automatique qu'on peut jouer et D5 ça va
être un jour aussi on aura envie de voir
chez les Noirs mais c'est pas possible
encore pour l'instant
F4
ok bon pourquoi pas la pièce que j'aime
pas c'est le pied droit en fait
un peu mieux par là quoi donc je pense
que ça va être un de ces plans à un
moment donné désactiver
comme ça
un peu que les pièces noires sont pas
forcément encore
si bien bon début elle fait un petit peu
défaut
la concrètement on peut même calculer le
ça part de marcher bien mais en fait tu
vois si là on est arrivé par exemple
je sais pas à quel point ça a l'air
bizarre
parce que tu m'inscris
donc moi ce que je voulais c'est de
faire du style pour ouvrir madame mais
bon juste je suis très fatigué le fou
des fantômes
[Musique]
donc j'ai rien mais
priori il avait toujours
on voit qu'il y a un droit à ta relation
et
j'aime pas à cause de H5 mais qui a un
coup bon donc tu parles tout à l'heure
H5 pour chasser le kng3 et peut-être
faire cahier H5 ou des choses comme ça
et d'ailleurs se prémunère contre les
futurs 5 et attaquer au passage depuis
un F4
et c'est vrai que avec ce que tu dis ça
vachement de sens genre ça par exemple
si tu fais H4 cavalier bouge et carénage
5 par exemple 5 le pion directement
devient une faiblesse parce qu'il est
pas défendu et sur 4 noir et ben c'est
un peu difficile on se retrouve c'était
fou
vont logiquement se changer un jour
F4 sera tout le temps à une faiblesse en
fait
H5 était joué quasiment
instantané c'est pas évident de le
trouver quoi quand elle leur dit ok tu
le vois mais on peut penser à d'autres
coups après c'est assez logique il fait
partie des coûts candidats mais il l'a
joué assez vite et ouais puis en plus
enfin je vais me faire quatre quoi
donc du roi c'est un réflexe qui qui est
pas si facile à avoir mais c'est vrai
que là en fait en gros la différence H6
CH5 c'est que H6 est défendait G5 la
plus bah non à part ça mais il y a
tellement pas de pièces blanches qui
peuvent en profiter il y a pas de qui
avait un F3 il y a pas de fou en C1 qui
est rangé 5 ou que en fait c'est un
affaiblissement qui est en état c'est
juste visuel donc bravo les deux
cavaliers sont mal placés ça c'est aussi
quelque chose d'important
à dire et c'est pour ça qu'on peut jouer
contre ce cavalier et même se fout en C2
bah écoute tant que j'ai pas réussi à
jouer 5 j'ai pas réussi à ouvrir la
position mon fils continuera à être
mauvais en fait en gros on aimerait
échanger le cabinet 3 contre et au moins
de posséder il pourra aller en B3 et
retrouver une belle diagonale aussi
il aurait plus d'options et là en fait
avec ces deux-là cinq ça change pas mal
de choses et
en tout cas ouais c'est H5 H4 dès qu'il
y a une pièce en G3 toute façon c'est
pour le prendre en compte ou à 5 à 4 de
l'autre côté d'ailleurs peut-être qu'on
verra les deux dans la partie d'ailleurs
je pense pas
en tout cas c'est une idée que qu'on
avait qu'on avait énoncé plusieurs fois
avant cette partie les liquide joua H5
et même avant même que le pion arrive en
F4 on en avait parlé pendant on en avait
parlé de ce quoi 5 sur les DF3 notamment
donc
quand il en F3 on attaque la case F4 là
on attaque sur la case mais le pion au
passage quoi mais c'est ça
[Musique]
franchement pourquoi pas ça pas l'air
absurde de faire ça juste on n'est pas
super bien mais on n'est pas foutu non
plus
est-ce que j'ai pas de dessin
[Musique]
et puis bon ben J'aurais une pièce et là
je commence à être content et sur puis
on prend ma store on avait parlé de ça
en plus qui va arriver je sais pas
moi
je souffre et les pièces blanches sont
tellement à droite à gauche sont pas
coordonnées
[Musique]
là
après avoir ce qui veut faire dessin que
ce que il veut faire cavalier
mais il y a pas non plus de truc qui
gagne sur le coup c'est juste les pièces
blanches sont pas au top on pourrait
penser un coup comme c'est si après
aussi peut-être pour rajouter de la
pression sur le centre simplement
en fait tous les coups
noirs sont pas mal en fait et ça c'est
un problème
quand même si tout est coupé
[Musique]
beaucoup de choix pour Fabien on va voir
ce qu'il choisit il est en plus il a
l'avantage à la pendule 330 contre 5 30
donc il y a 2 minutes d'avance donc il
peut bien réfléchir une bonne minute et
garder l'antager la pendule et trouver
une salle couille
d'avance et puis il a une position qui
qui est pas mal je pense on va même
aussi la jauge et en plus il a besoin de
du nul c'est ça qui oui
[Musique]
ça va proposer l'échange des fous de
cases noires et en même temps ça laisse
le cavalier H1 passif puisque si il
revient en F2 il y aura la fourchette en
G3 est-ce que là peut-être
je vais galérer des cartes c'est trop de
ma place cavalier pour mettre le four en
métro
prendre le B2
[Musique]
j'ai besoin d'activer en fait
que juste
[Musique]
c'est un coup d'attaque qui n'est pas
bon en fait
mais attention c'est faire attention à
quelqu'un que c'est pour ça que j'oublie
[Musique]
il est content d'échanger et sécurisé
mais genre l'ordi pour bien si c'est
soit faite 5 ça va pas il propose à G5
côté
ici là
d'enlever le pion F4 c'est ça l'idée en
fait c'est pour avoir la case de 5 pour
ton cahier tu as tout quoi et qu'en fait
le droit s'ouvre mais en fait c'est il
s'ouvre pour tout le monde
c'est que c'est que F5 toi-même avec les
Blancs ça peut pas être une option SI
propose G5 pour provoquer
cinq
c'est vraiment pas un bon coup ça c'est
c'est clair et donc mauvais coup de
jouer à partager c'est la bonne nouvelle
mais je vois un coup rouge je pars vu
juste derrière apparemment
alors pourquoi sur l'Obs je crois que tu
as un problème
avant la caméra
[Musique]
et que tu es pas loin d'égalité et que
tu en F3 ça reste comme ça mais comme on
dit de toute façon il doit jouer le gain
donc
toi moi je peux pas dire toi trois fois
[Musique]
en fait on a parlé ça tombe bien en fait
d'avoir
les pièces juste
donc P3 mais il va se battre du lin il
va se battre il faut il faut il faut
mais comment on dit le problème c'est
que il suffit pas de sauver nul quoi
faut qu'à m'en gagner
4 il veut il veut prendre ses cadres et
essayer de manger deux pièces et
peut-être si je prends ces quatre je
reprends non
mais bon
ça que ça donne bon moi ça donne une
incertitude oui au moins c'est ça reste
on peut se tromper quoi
ça va forcer un peu les Noirs à
cavalier à moins que tu vois si je fais
cavaler B6 elle avait trois quatre cinq
[Musique]
ok bah écoute ça ça donne une chance
pratique à jouer dans tout cas
il aura quoi deux pions pour contre deux
pièces et j'ai vu la tête de famille
après il était un peu un peu d'oeil dans
le sens où il sent qu'il a qui donne du
jeu
objectivement bien joué mais vu la
pression qu'il avait tu es pas content
de rentrer dans un truc à couteau tirer
comme ça ouais parce que là bon bah
pose-moi compliqué il y a quand même il
y a deux pièces pour la tour mais il y a
deux pions pour les noirs qui sont
d'ailleurs qui peuvent être faibles
aussi et un peu passé donc bon c'est
c'est chaud mais c'est vrai que quand on
est gagnant on veut tout faire sauf de
les jeux l'adversaire exactement
[Musique]
et oui là on sent que il faut faire
attention alors que si il avait
vu le B3 et ben il aurait sûrement pas
joué il aurait essayé de plus solide
plus tranquille
faut prendre ces quatre et quatre
[Musique]
ça va pas ensemble quoi
il y avait pas échec je crois que j'ai
compris
[Musique]
il a buggé mais en fait ça va donc X4 ok
donc il veut échanger le full bloqueur
en C2
et plus de 50 secondes
à faire et il fallait manger des pions
quand même
on peut imaginer alors je sais pas en
quel sens peut-être ça ça
une tour peut être plus forte que deux
pièces mineures en finale si surtout si
on a un peu passé et cavaliers sont pas
actifs donc si jamais j'arrive à vite
réagir un canard ça peut le faire mais
par exemple des trois ça peut être trop
tard ça peut être tombé les uns après
les autres parce que deux pièces peuvent
se coordonner pour attaquer un pion
alors qu'une tour toute seule défend
donc tu es toujours à deux contre un
c'est ça
pour ça qu'il faut vite ramener le roi
et c'est là tu vois les pions ils vont
un peu tous tomber en fait elles sont
tous isolés donc s'il arrive à être le
roi en Détroit écoute
et là il y a de Laurent
faites pas mal donc 50 secondes dans la
pendule pour pour Jules contre une
minute 25
tours
donc bon il y a un rajout de temps quand
même mais Julia ne parlait du fait que
ben il a
il
stresse pas mal c'est bizarre quand tu
as une compétition comme ça online et en
fait il se rend compte que il stresse
beaucoup plus et il joue pas pareil que
quand ils ouvraient normalement
c'est à dire que si il est devant chez
lui et qui pour rien pour rigoler il va
jouer des coupes facilement que là il
réfléchit un peu plus il a plus de
pression en fait non bah oui bah déjà il
y a de l'enjeu financier il y a le fait
aussi que ce soit suivi donc tu joues
devant des gens
et tu as pas envie de passer pour un
idiot mais ça il en parlait hier
et à chaque fois je regarde à Fabienne
c'est vrai que tu la trompe donc
je sais pas si tu as vu ce qu'il a fait
contre vent de Forest
pas trop il a raskit ah bon il a pas
abandonné il est parti
surtout qu'il y a plus de temps de part
et d'autre donc bon après ça se joue au
clic un peu et ça se joue au clic mais
hier on a vu Fabien qui a qui a réussi à
trouver une énorme défense contre les
raisins tu es complètement foutu et
c'était compliqué et arrête toujours à
trouver du jeu et faire des choses c'est
pas une fourchette quand même
il est faible à son tour
conservateur mais bon en fait
il est pas trop faible le rendez 4 non
non il est bien il menace de prendre des
seins il peut lancer ouais bon ok
pourquoi pas en fait
le roi il aurait interféré mais ça
sera bien mieux avoir échanger cette
tour et ils l'ont pas fait
alors bon chacun écoute il peut se
passer plein de trucs
ok
qu'est-ce qui se passe là qui fait
encore il fait des mimiques il a des
grosses limites de merde
je peux comprendre qui m'imitive
à la chasse à la tour en fait il va
échanger absolument la tour on va faire
trois quatre je pense
que là je me mets
j'aurais juste tellement fait tour à 4
vite à sa place
donner une tour contre un des cavaliers
mais ça va échec comment je matte là
comment je mate
c'est gagné et Jules qui a gagné
incroyable incroyable incroyable
Jules qui égalise face à carvana c'est
incroyable grosse partie
le début était pas bien ça on va on va
pas
c'est clair mais en fait Fabiano c'est
un peu emmêlé les pinceaux complètement
à partir du moment où il a fait ce G5 en
fait
jusque là c'est parfait et là déjà tu
vas leur dire pas très bien et
bon il reste mieux mais en fait ouais B3
d'un coup là tu es obligé de rentrer
d'un truc concret et il y avait pas en
fait de faire ça
pour rien
tu pouvais t'en passer quoi
[Musique]
et alors après
donc un partout donc là on va avoir un
départage donc normalement il y a une
pause alors je sais que sur le slack
tiens au courant de tout ça et en fait
là ce qui va se passer c'est que les
joueurs les joueurs vont tous les deux
écrire à l'arbitre un message privé avec
un petit temps il vous proposer un temps
à avoir et en fait ce qui va faire
attends une seconde
voilà dans 10 minutes donc on va faire
un petit pause avant je pense dans 10
minutes
on va avoir les temps pour l'Armageddon
celui de la partie qui va commencer donc
qui va se passer là en fait c'est que
les deux joueurs là vous savez qui reste
une seule partie pour se partager
l'Armageddon en quoi ça consiste en fait
ça consiste à faire une seule partie une
dernière partie si tu veux pour
départager les joueurs et en cas
d'égalité c'est noir qui vont gagner et
qui se qualifiant et
l'idée c'est que pour partager les Noirs
tu veux bien pour deux résultats et bien
les Noirs resteront moins de temps à la
pendule que les Blancs donc là comme les
deux peut-être veulent les Noirs c'est
pas trop ce qui va se passer et bien
dans tous les cas il va falloir faire
une sorte de
comment appelle ça
Paris quoi si tu veux
et celui qui met le temps le plus bas
gagne l'enchère et aura le temps qu'il
aura écrit contre 15 minutes par exemple
je dis n'importe quoi Jules il va
marquer 9 minutes
et qui aura la va marquer par exemple 10
minutes et ben Jules qui aura mis 10
minutes et qui ramène 9 minutes
il aura les Noirs dans la partie avec le
temps qu'il a posé donc 9 minutes contre
15 du coup 15 c'est le temps normal et
en plus tu es bonne
[Musique]
donc c'est du chaos donc si vous voulez
sur le chat je vous laisse écrire un
petit peu comme le copain mettre un
petit peu les enchères que vous pensez
qu'ils vont qui vont mettre est-ce que
tu as une idée toi de ce qui pourrait
mettre 15
et en plus de temps la pendule
il y a un ok mais il a quand même
souffrir dans les deux parties je trouve
ah bah oui mais du coup autant que tu
joues pour prendre l'avantage à la
pendule et tu mets ma tête sous l'eau
quoi tu cliques vite tu peux jouer vite
ou tu peux jouer pour serrer les fesses
sont possibles mais c'est pas qu'elle va
être qu'elle va être le choix de de
Jules ici
[Musique]
j'ai pas envie de me prendre la pression
à la pendule je traite 12008 à sa place
un truc comme ça
parce que bah il y a un et on est dans
la poule déperdant donc la poule
déperdant vous savez que il y a que deux
matchs donc là il y a eu un 1 à l'essuie
les deux matchs donc
qui va avoir lieu donc là on va attendre
les résultats donc si vous voulez
repartir en pause parce que nous il faut
qu'on vous mette les pubs de
[Musique]
voilà on est là pour les sponsors et moi
je guette je vais rester là je vais
guetter un petit peu les sondages et dès
que j'ai la partie et ben je reviens
avec les sondages et on vous retenait un
peu tout ce qui va se passer etc en tout
cas Jules qui qui voudra ma guidon
contre contre
dans ce match va loin pour le tirer
quatre rapide
et je peux aussi vous mettre si vous
voulez le petit bracket qui va avec le
bracket vous avez ici
à la grande finale qui va attendre le
gagnant de vente forest contre un des
deux entre cawana et Moussa donc le
joueur qui va gagner dans le magasin
jour avant de Forest et le gagnant des
deux je vous raconte
voilà donc parti hyper importante
pour Jules ici Jules qui qui a battu
carvana qui a réussi à égaliser le score
sur demande donc voilà super
je vais revenir là dessus et puis et
puis je pense qu'on va partir en pause
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et nous sommes de retour la partie a
commencé donc on a vu ici un
parti pardon donc Jules qui a des blancs
qui commencent à 15 minutes contre 9 58
jules a gagné enfin perdu l'ancien mais
je pense qu'il a gagné l'enfer
rapidos et
je vous enlevez le son des caméras
peut-être c'est cool
elles sont des caméras
je sais pas je l'ai enlevé au cas où
mais je sais pas si vous entendiez je
sais pas si vous entendiez je la
reconnais les vieux bruits des mecs qui
tournent
non mais oui le son de ce qui se passe
chez life chez l'autre
[Musique]
ouais donc bon ok on en est par là c'est
ça
yes allez on est deux
donc standard ici là on a un stage de
d'espace mais elle a peur de fou chez
noir on a aussi un emballage de
structure on a ici quatre pions contre 3
donc de ce côté chéquier et de l'autre
on a trois contre quatre donc là c'est
une structure à cette thématique
en fait il faut savoir que s'il y a plus
de pièces si tu changes toutes les
pièces et que tu laisses que des pions
cette finale va être gagnante pour les
blancs parce que ben en fait je vais
facilement créer un pion passé monter
mon roi et gagner et de ton côté en fait
tu pourras jamais passer quatre contre
trois ça passe jamais jamais jamais
à condition de ne pas te faire échanger
un pion bêtement
faut pas que les Nord fasse les blancs
fassent exprès de rendre la majorité
adversaire par exemple on va imaginer si
vous voulez que pièce
il y a plusieurs façons d'obtenir avec
les Blancs c'est de faire une petite
toi comme ça
soit levé tu en parlais comme ça et
imaginons lever pour être en B2 C3
encore une fois on est bien on imagine
la police et ben ici en fait et ben j'ai
par exemple B5
et je bouge pas si je prends bien
évidemment il va manger et là il a une
majorité vous prenez bien et l'idée en
fait c'est que si je passe mon tour
coup illégal d'ailleurs que j'ai pas de
temps
mais si il prend je prends et en fait tu
as pas de majorité et tu fais ça ben
quand tu prends je prends en fait
six c'est absolument rien dans pour
jouer une majorité quoi
pour les blancs dans cette position
maintenant qu'on a compris ça on peut se
dire bah en fait on échange tout c'est
gagné quoi donc bien sûr les Noirs le
savent donc ils vont pas tout échanger
tiens gentil tiens on échange tout non
c'est pas comme ça se passe surtout que
voilà en face ça c'est autre chose qu'on
connaît et moi je me souviens elle avait
vu une position un peu de même type il y
a très longtemps et j'avais eu
l'opportunité de porte tout échanger
c'était quand même
et on pouvait tout échanger
et je l'ai pas fait moi je veux un soir
à 2100 j'avais 2003 déjà
et
il m'avait dit pourquoi tu avais changé
et moi je lui ai dit
parce que ça
va faire nulle
avec donc
j'avais 2300 et je trouve que c'était
pas au final que tu dois connaître quand
tu parles juste de la pollution ce
premier cours quoi
sur cette position entendre en terme de
structure d'avion et donc c'était grave
mais bon maintenant je vais pas
maintenant je connais
et ça sert à ça dans les idées c'est
parti ah oui des fois on fait des
conneries et puis bah après faut les
retenir et encore mieux si on analyse et
qu'on en retient des concepts des pas
juste des coups et j'aurais dû faire
quel F3 bon ça on s'en fout en fait mais
de retenir des concepts comme ça ça
c'est utile toute la vie
mais non
tu as pas besoin de calculer la finale
tu sais tu sais que ça gagne
et donc donc voilà après bon ça passe
simple que ça en compensation de tout ce
que tu as donné enfin de du fait que
plus de chance de pièces mieux tuer bah
les Noirs ils ont quand même une paire
de fou
les plombs ont doublé ou un rôle quand
même plein de cartes entre elles aussi
donc les noirs doivent juste enfin les
blancs d'avaient c'est juste d'échanger
mais les Noirs vont essayer de pas trop
échanger garder des pièces et finalement
ils sont quand la position
si jamais j'arrive à échanger la
structure maintenant plus tard le 32
pourra passer
donc sur il y a eu tourné il y a pas eu
de Cavalière
si tu prends je prenais là
[Musique]
je trouve ça enfin de toute façon il
peut toujours le faire plus tard mais
pas bête si tu défends avec B6 j'aurais
peut-être des B4 un jour quoi
dans toutes ces structures de roselymo
aussi en tout cas c'est comme ça
donc ça peut être utile mais je trouve
que c'est bien
que Jules genre position en fait
parce que il y a moins calcu hyper bon
en calcul quoi c'est ça c'est un camp de
force mais là en fait tu as rien à
calculer c'est plus du placement de
pièces et il peut calculer et pédaler
dans la foule en fait
donc c'est plutôt le même position après
en soit
la pression noir il y a pas il y a pas
de problème c'est c'est correct mais je
trouve ça un choix pas bête plutôt
retourné dans une Espagnole finalement
car on a maîtrise mieux quoi classique
je veux dire comme la partie d'avant
là tu peux jouer
ok c'est juste solide ça va mais ça se
finit au chaos donc bon malheureusement
en fait on a plus vraiment davantage à
la pendule mais peut-être si tu arrives
à une partie comme tout à l'heure où on
a une minute chacun ça se finit à la fin
de beaucoup plus irrationnel ce qui se
passe et tout peut arriver quoi sauf que
là en plus ce qui se passe c'est qu'il y
a pas de rajoutant il y a pas
d'incrément donc là c'est du chaos et il
me semble qu'en clic et en Bullet Julie
il est pas mal hein
en bitibulette
il est en tout cas je pense hein en
chaos d'ailleurs il y avait eu un match
de Bullet
entre mvl et Jules
organisé ou sur internet sur internet
il y avait il y avait je sais plus
c'était pendant une heure un truc comme
ça toujours qu'on a une heure et je
l'avais gagné donc bon ça monte quand
même que ambulette
clairement bon et c'est un peu une
grande force par exemple faut pas que ça
trop mal au temps il faudrait qu'il
arrive à à suivre Fabiano et le pousser
à une position où ça peut être chaud
ça c'est clair mais mais s'il arrive à
jouer vite et à mettre un peu la
pression ça peut être pas mal d'ailleurs
fabuleux qui joue vite hein franchement
les joues vite il a raison en fait il a
bien géré il faut bien non parce qu'en
fait il a fait son retard à la pendule
pas même plus et il est pas moins bien
l'échiquier donc il peut être content de
ce qu'il a accompli jusqu'à présent
après je vous rappelle qu'on a encore
dans l'optique et changer les pièces et
d'avoir cette année donc toi il a changé
les tours ils font le cavalier
[Musique]
un peu c'est que la structure noire elle
est quand même pas simple à gérer c'est
un peu dur de vraiment
[Musique]
gérer la structure
B n'est plus ensemble toutes les figé
quoi toutes les sujets on pourrait
prendre des trois ça change un peu la
donne des trois donc cette structure là
pour le coup je sais pas ce que ça donne
je l'ai jamais étudié
du coup je sais pas si on échange tout
si on gagne aussi la finale tu vois pour
le coup
mais bon en tout cas les Noirs je les
vois pas aller faire de même un fouet
pour aller bouffer le cavalier quoi ils
vont
plus rien faire
contre vent forest one forest qui est
qui j'imagine en train de regarder ce
qui se passe dans cette partie et elle
tient d'ailleurs ouais ça reprend direct
après 23 alors j'ai 5 ok il veut pas
rien faire il joue pendant tout échanger
là-bas ok pas bah j'ai pas pensé du tout
on a une minute de décalage par rapport
à vous
quand vous écrivez un message
généralement le voir plus ou moins tempo
par contre quand vous
quand on vous répond ben vous le vous
écoutez les commentaires une minute
après donc des fois on n'est pas synchro
par rapport à ce qu'on raconte par
rapport à ce que vous proposez je suis
désolé
le délai d'une minute ouais bah c'est
une mesure antitriche que j'aime bien
enfin après je sais pas tu as une minute
c'est peut-être même pas ça devrait dire
mais en gros c'est ce que la fille
décide de faire dans les tournois aussi
c'est de mettre un délai de un quart
d'heure
lorsque ça cesse faudrait pas une
demi-heure tant qu'on y est ou je sais
pas moi mais
le truc c'est qu'effectivement bah
si tu joues en direction internet en
gros le truc et que tu as un complice
qui voit la partie et que tu as moins de
communication
mais il peut te dire le coup à jouer
alors que si il y a un décalage bon bah
soit tu attends mais quand c'est du bled
ou du c'est plus dur et quand il y a un
quart d'heure dans les parties lentes tu
vas pas le faire à chaque coup quoi et
là donc c'est ça leur idée en fait de ce
délai alors c'est chiant quand on casse
parce que du coup on peut plus interagir
en direct avec vous mais ça s'explique
comme ça alors leur décision en fait
de de pas pouvoir suivre les parties
soi-même sur Internet pas si vous vous
essayez tous les particules sur vous
allez voir que ça marchera pas quoi et
moi j'ai un lien secret qui s'appelle ça
secrète
Link pour pouvoir suivre l'événement et
événement aussi quoi genre moi je la
vois la partie en direct mais j'ai un
délai par rapport à ce qu'on a nous moi
j'en suis à G7 G5 en fait
ah oui tu as trop de retard et plusieurs
minutes
faudrait 10 minutes ouais en fait après
je pense aussi tu vois oui tu peux
tricher on a vu des cas par exemple même
là en fait nous on met l'ordi
bah écoute je vais te suivre et mettre
l'ordinateur et en fait je suis à
l'autre bout de la maison et tu pars
c'est devenu tellement
simple le mettre un délai
ça prévient quand même pas mal parce que
c'est vrai que maintenant déjà cette
cette
façon de tricher on n'est plus possible
grâce à ça mais après c'est vrai que
pour le stream c'est chiant quoi on peut
pas parler de moi bien
mais en gros pour vous vous êtes en
condition réelle quoi voilà
donc ok réussi en tout cas jouer
parce que même un des quatre on a pas
envie de le faire à l'intérieur on a pas
de la structure du fait que on a une
majorité au centre et que les Nord ont
une majorité là mais qui n'avance jamais
et si je fais des cadres la majorité se
rétablit quoi
il y aura trois comptes de ici pour les
noirs avec la paire de fou ce qu'on veut
pas
est-ce que je peux peut-être un jour je
sais pas j'aime pas mais c'est de manger
et faire quatre quoi pardon mes flèches
qui marchent pas
un F6 ouais bah après le truc c'est que
le roi aussi va tourner là-bas il va
bloquer le pion est passé mais peut-être
qu'à un moment faudra passer par là
parce que on a du mal à avancer
mais donc
il y a décidé de rien faire il a raison
aussi
avec les Noirs dans l'armée Guédon il
peut se contenter de la nul donc je le
ramène le cavalier peut-être direction
F2H pour attaquer un peu le pion G5
en tout cas je pense qu'en Bullet enfin
dans la phase chaos Jules c'est vraiment
là qui peut vraiment mettre carbone en
PLS et d'en faire durer la partie c'est
pas mal en soi de toute façon il a pas
le choix
et d'espérer justement ce scénario
parce que maintenant qu'il va jouer
cavalier H3 il va provoquer un peu roi
G6
mais si j'arrive à jouer 5 ou des 500 de
formater avec tous les cinq matchs qui
seraient un peu la loose ça peut en tout
cas il bouge le sac là il y a aussi à
quatre maintenant qui est menacé avec la
avec mes problèmes ici mais bon j'arrive
à attendre mais ouais mais Fabiano il
gère pas mal ils arrivent pas mal de
pions
il a pas peur de les pousser donc
ça va être on croise les deux je suis
plutôt d'accord avec toi alors ça
pourrait être assez trop aussi mais vaut
mieux faire ça que d'aller encore
prendre un cadre donc
maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on va faire avec
les avec les Blancs parce que B4 qu'on
veut pas Descartes on veut pas en fait
on veut faire quoi
non non bah disons en fait objectivement
la pression noir
20e
il va peut-être juste échanger ramener
le roi Versatis et 5 alors ça est-ce
qu'il part sur toutes les quatre
c'est quand même une grosse une grosse
décision on va dire c'est peut-être un
très bon coup mais c'est une décision
parce que tu sais qu'il faut ça tu tiens
sans trop faire grand chose et
d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'il a fait
je veux dire ouais
je peux comprendre mais ça a l'air pas
mal fous des quatre mais en fait quand
tu as un setup qui tient et que tu peux
nulle te suffit alors il le provoque en
fait peut-être qu'il va quand même le
faire maintenant fout des cas non il
prend des personnes là oui il a créé la
faiblesse avec B4 et maintenant le roi
qui va monter pas mal et Roy F6
hyper passif
que prendre la nul ça équivaut à
abandonner et là pour gagner ce très
bonne chance
par la force des choses mais mais oui
nul ça lui va très bien voilà c'est
pareil en fait
Seigneur quoi
il a fait un et demi sur enfin
franchement pas loin
bon après carvana il a plutôt deviné le
match dans le contenu mais ouais peu de
choses près ça pouvait ça pouvait un peu
tourner ouais c'est ça donc alors Jules
les amis qu'il allait nous rejoindre je
vais je vais je vais voir si
je lui écrire j'ai passé normalement et
que je regarde est-ce que tu sais à
quelle heure c'est censé jouer le
normalement ça va enchaîner
[Musique]
et reprendre direct donc toi si tu
prends une pause je sais pas vas-y
pas trop loin et de toute façon je vais
je vais voir avec
mon téléphone avec mon cas où et tu me
dis ouais de toute façon je vais je vais
voir quand est-ce qu'il veut qui veut
passer si le passé maintenant s'il veut
passer après si le bas j'ai tout court
et puis et puis on revient avec Jules
façon ou pas
à tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes de retour avec Jules sur le
stream salut nul salut alors un petit
peu tes impressions après la défaite
contre
contre Faby
la première je me suis emmêlé les
pinceaux parce que je connais ce truc
très rare mais c'est un truc que j'avais
regardé mais je me rappelais plus
exactement ce qu'il fallait faire et
j'ai oublié un détail après j'avais une
poubelle c'était trop dur à jouer bien
jouer en plus
la deuxième mustwin avec les blancs
comme hier
vraiment moins bien et il joue ce G5
heureusement et après je l'ai bien
embrouillé
ça c'était sympa
non mon cœur vous avez plus de temps
mais nous on voit le groupe point
d'interrogation qui arrive tu vois ok
mais c'était quand tu joues quand il
attend à 3 en fait et en fait
c'est mignon
chercher à mater ou suivre le matin
je vais prendre ses pions je veux faire
un truc mais j'ai pas pensé à enfermé
là-dedans ça a bien marché
[Musique]
je sais pas combien de temps j'avais 16
secondes c'est pas évident mais c'est
joli en plus j'aurais pu y penser parce
que j'ai eu
j'ai vu un truc similaire l'épo karaté
un truc très similaire avec moi en
Bundesliga en partie longue où il
enferme une tour comme ça c'est un peu
avec un cavalier il amène le roi
j'aurais pu j'aurais pu penser avec un
peu plus de temps je pense mais là ok
tu as la pression la [__] de prendre
tu dis allez ouais j'ai le pion ouais le
pion h en plus c'est des pions que je
voulais absolument prendre parce que en
fait il y a des cas avant ou tu sais il
peut me mater avec les deux tours sur la
première avec une force à mettre le
orange 2
donc je voulais absolument ouais plutôt
donc en fait dans ma tête fallait
absolument que je les élimine et puis il
faut remonter bien avant
il y a un moment où ouais s'il fait un
truc du style tour B8 tu vois tout de
suite
ouais un truc comme ça mettons ça t'en
prends ces trois tourbes bien tu
reprends à deux
dans ma tête je devais éviter ce genre
de truc OK
mais
c'est pour ça que je voulais prendre les
pions après je pense que toute manière
qui avait laissé trois c'est
pas du tout du tout pensé et ouais après
je sais pas si j'étais gagnant ça avait
l'air bien après quand je fais j'ai 4 et
tout mais non mais
après techniquement c'est plutôt bien et
puis c'est très dur pour les Noirs en
fait mais je me demandais si c'était pas
un bluff mon truc est-ce que j'avais
vraiment mat ou est-ce qu'il avait le
temps
que je leur disais que c'était peut-être
possible mais
[Musique]
le droit G7 vers la fin
bah oui oui il donne un truc mais
moi j'essaie de mauvais coup
c'est un cauchemar fallait jouer quoi au
lieu de Roger
moi je pensais à 4 ouais
et heureusement parce que la carte je
voyais pas ce que je faisais en fait
c'était là j'étais en bluff complet
et qu'est-ce que je fais je suis pas sûr
peut-être qu'il faut que je joue au
racket cavalier H5 ouais
7 à Tours C6 quand même ça peut être
chaud c'est vrai que ça fait peur avec
cette seconde
c'est chaud en fait je comprends les
deux c'est la course
[Musique]
il a regardé c'est la semaine dernière
si je joue ça et qui connaît pas
exactement quoi faire ça peut être alors
c'est jamais gagnant mais il y a une
légère pression que tu peux tu vois
c'est pas si facile à jouer pour
longtemps et je peux flag et je pensais
que c'était malin mais en fait il savait
exactement quoi faire c'est écrit un peu
du coup c'est la galère
parce que par exemple là si tu connais
pas c'est pas déjà
connu mais c'est précis sinon il est
moins bien
après qu'elle avait lieu deux fois 6 bon
coup aussi B3 en Europe tout ça c'est
alors c'est pas des seuls coups mais tu
si tu connais pas tu peux perdre du
temps à dire ok est-ce que je prends du
pion est-ce que je prends du Fou même
après faut prendre qui avait laissé
trois faut jouer cavalier des 7 sinon il
y a une petite pression
c'est pas grave c'est vrai que tu as
tout fait très vite en fait ouais
c'est chiant
et puis à chaque fois
ça veut dire
parce que si je joue pas H5
il peut y avoir une espèce de petite
pression moi je joue à 5 G4
j'essaie de pousser alors c'est pas
grand chose mais bon
[Musique]
je savais pas exactement quoi faire je
me rappelle plus
j'ai joué assez correct
mais c'est vrai que même sans C6 ou quoi
ça va alors que c'est pas évident à
jouer je crois
ça fait ça fait peur
ouais c'est ça et j'y croyais pas trop
trop au début mais en fait c'est faux je
pense que c'est ça
mais qu'est-ce que je fais en fait c'est
ça le problème
j'arrive jamais à faire
les gens qui regardent c'est tout casser
mais bon j'ai adoré aussi puis il y a du
cavalier qui a plein de trucs
il y a trop de je peux jouer C4 mais C4
jouer parce que je faisais parce que de
toute façon j'ai pas trop d'idées après
ces quatre je voyais pas G6 par exemple
comme
je voyais pas comment jouer en fait
parce que dès que je recule le cavalier
je peux me retrouver moins bien avec les
ça ressemble à auberlinoise
ou s'il commence à s'activer de ce côté
là ça peut être dangereux et moi
j'arrive pas à créer du jeu sur la loi
avec mes pions avec majorité
en fait c'est pour ça que j'ai voulu
changer le cavalier un peu plus tard
mais pour essayer de créer quelque chose
mais après il y a plus assez de pièces
en fait c'est bien mais j'ai plus de
pièces
du coup peut-être que je dois jouer Road
2 C4
et
après qu'elle allait des trois pour
peut-être reprendre du roi
mais non de ces quatre mois je me disais
OK
[Musique]
c'est un peu ouais c'est lui-même m'a
dit pas de chance j'ai regardé ça j'ai
regardé B3 il y a
sur une partie qui peut être importante
au moins l'avantage d'avoir les blancs
dans ta partie c'est que tu as plus de
temps la pendule ouais après c'était
marrant parce que j'ai dit que j'ai bide
on a le système de bide là et j'ai mis
10 minutes 25 j'ai voulu changer à la
dernière seconde pour 9,47 et je crois
qu'il a mis 9-48 non
je peux vérifier
ou Fortis eight et du coup je me suis
dit une seconde près ça aurait été drôle
et toi tu voulais tu voulais les blancs
je me fais défoncer quoi
alors avec cinq minutes de moins en plus
je sais pas évidemment maintenant je
regrette un peu mais bon c'est dur de
savoir parce que
dans ces matchs ou la dynamique c'est
gagner gagner pareil car on a fait
quasiment que gagner perdre dans
beaucoup beaucoup de résultats décisifs
donc les blancs c'est pas si mal après
ouais maintenant je regrette un peu
peut-être le choix d'ouverture mais
après c'est pas facile pour tu peux pas
te douter moi je trouvais que c'était
malin en fait mais ouais moi aussi mais
bon bah oui enfin on savait pas qu'il
allait être regardé non plus je l'ai vu
jouer pas mal de de ces Espagnols
d'échanges là il fait des trucs assez
actifs normalement
et là ouais je suis mal tombé parce que
si regarde pas ça la semaine dernière
peut-être qu'il me joue autre chose et
ok on a une partie là c'est vraiment la
ligne pour tuer en plus il est fermé
quoi
à la fin les gens demandaient mais
pourquoi il a fait nul alors qu'il a -7
bon bah l'idée c'est que c'est que tu
vois donc pour gagner du temps ça
changera oui enfin c'est pareil c'est la
même chose hein armage
et les Noirs en cas de nulle sont
qualifiés donc c'est pour ça que tu as
donné le pion j'ai enfin c'est pour ça
qu'en fait à la fin j'ai tenté un truc
mais bon j'y croyais j'ai plus de chance
de gagner au loto que de gagner la
finale clairement ouais mais bon vu que
la nulle te fait perdre il faut tenter
tout quoi
de jouer des matchs ces mecs c'est assez
sérieux mine de rien les mecs ils se
préparent même Carolin il le prend il le
prend au sérieux il se prépare
il arrive pas non plus ça fait un
entraînement aussi pour la Coupe du
monde non c'est clair c'est clair
où il doit faire nul où il doit
il sait son corps son mental est habitué
à ça
c'est un peu moins le cas pour tous les
hordogs du tournoi quoi
même Abdou même si ouais mais
bon
il connaît pas ça
mais non mais en tout cas façon moi je
vais pas me je vais pas me plaindre je
suis déjà je suis déjà content d'être là
je devais pas être là déjà parce que
j'ai perdu le match contre j'ai été
repêché
je voulais même pas jouer le play-in
parce que j'étais crevé je me suis dit
que ça allait servir à rien donc
vraiment c'est que du bonus
parce que surtout que j'avais derrière
je jouais Garden avec contre qui j'ai un
Super Sport
un peu moins un peu moins fort que
le Carona oui quand même bah c'est une
question
de ce truc de tu sais tu as des
adversaires
j'ai vraiment un super sport que ce soit
long donc c'est un peu le regret mais
bon j'espère qu'il va j'espère qu'il va
gagner ou alors j'espère que le carbone
again comme ça je me dis que j'aurais
perdu mes deux matchs contre les
finalistes
c'est toujours mieux comme au poker tu
sais quand tu te fais éliminer du temps
et tu dis quoi
[Musique]
ok bah écoute bon bah fin de fin de ton
import pour toi et puis bah de toute
façon je pense que maintenant il y a pas
de il y a pas de qualification genre là
il faut refaire depuis le début non
ouais c'est ça c'est le 12
[Musique]
12 juin le prochain
général parce qualifier pour la dernière
étape c'est ça mais c'est ça que rien
que arrivé en finale c'est peut-être
c'est énorme parce que tu as
cumules une tonne de une tonne de points
des prix dans tous les sens et
automatiquement qualifié pour la
division d'après c'est énorme
[Musique]
mais bon
bouton
c'est cool d'avoir montré d'ailleurs à
gagner cette deuxième partie montrer un
peu que
montrer un peu que voilà on n'est pas
non plus là par hasard tu vois les mecs
qui sont arrivés
mec un peu en dessous on est capable de
pas mal jouer poser des problèmes assez
mecs là non c'est clair franchement ça
fait un super parcours enfin super
parcours et puis et puis bon attention
en tout cas de revenir
dans ce temps là etc et de continuer un
petit peu ta progression et en tout cas
nous ça avait été un plaisir de te
suivre et puis aussi de t'avoir sur le
stream c'est vrai que que
les commentaires ces trucs là toujours
envie de jouer maintenant je joue et je
finis ça veut dire que d'être à jour je
l'aurais moi aussi quoi
un mois pour passer le grand maître
bon courage courage mais ouais non en
tout cas ce que je retiens quand même
d'un point de vue perso c'est des prépas
j'ai pas le niveau théorique pour pour
jouer ces trucs là les mecs qui sont
toujours une petite idée un truc
je suis en pratique
en plus se [__] je suis dégoûté parce
que je l'ai analysé il y a longtemps on
l'avait regardé avec Maxime Maxime bien
joué d'ailleurs une fois
c'était nouveau à l'époque et je me
rappelle plus en fait il y a un piège
j'ai oublié j'ai joué trois fuites après
je suis mal c'était dommage mais bon
en plus j'ai failli le regarder
[Rires]
un petit peu le sol quand tu as joué
quand il a joué
j'étais sur chaise bas j'avais les
doigts sur la flèche j'ai vu fou et
trois j'ai cliqué sur fouet 3 j'ai eu la
pause j'ai vu le coup
il y a plus important quand même
dégue mais bon c'est la vie
très intéressant tu sais que l'année
prochaine nous on va
à Cannes on se qualifié aussi pour Top
16 OK et donc bon on sera là quoi ok on
se verra l'année prochaine du coup il y
a de belles chances
c'est bon
[Rires]
ils ont des chances pour que je pense
que vous pouvez vous maintenir je pense
que c'est je pense que c'est jouable
c'est l'objectif comme chaque année de
toute façon bien
allez à bientôt Jules et merci beaucoup
ciao bonne soirée merci
[Musique]
qui vient de nous quitter alors c'est
laquelle
j'ai mis
un peu comment je voulais appeler cette
caméra
voilà je peux savoir tu veux que je
modifie mon son et je repasse sur le
discord on reste comme ça on va repartir
et
[Musique]
et ok donc ça remarche bien
oui pardon
attends en fait tout à l'heure j'ai pas
vu le j'ai pas vu le truc mais il est
possible que j'avais oublié il y a pas
de découpe peut-être un
je sais pas si j'ai pas fait gaffe il
est possible que j'avais oublié de
couper le micro sur l'autre et peut-être
qu'il y avait un écrou un écho en fait
du coup tu m'entends c'est bon moi
j'entends bien et toi
on dirait ah non non c'est bon pardon je
l'avais coupé
en tout cas bonjour à ceux qui viennent
d'arriver et ouais je vu le Jules qui
arrive du coup quatrième année tournoi
donc c'est c'est hyper bien c'est hyper
beau bon résultat et beau parcours et
puis
et puis bon on espérait que l'aventure
continue mais bon enfin c'est karwana
c'est pas facile et Julian qui c'est
quand même bien battu hein il a il a
pris une partie à carvana il a forcé
l'Armageddon
et derrière un magasin c'était spécial
c'est une partie difficile et bon il a
fait un perdu mais
voilà où on en est donc là on suit la
finale des perdants qui est entre vente
forest qui a les blancs alors je vous
enlever le score bande forest avec les
Blancs qui jouent contre carvana
italienne ou je peux alors
probablement mais
et
en fait le gagnant de cette partie
affrontera en finale
pour la grande finale de l'événement et
qu'est-ce que tu en penses alors ce
double bracket
bah en fait
je trouvais ça bizarre
et puis en fait je trouve que c'est cool
de laisser une chance
en fait le tournoi qui perd pas tu vois
et bon normalement quand tu perds tu
perds
mais mais là mais là je sais pas c'était
je trouve que c'est intéressant en fait
parce que voilà tu laisses une chance
pas tu peux faire un produit tu laisses
pas vraiment tu vas revenir après
pour voir non je trouve ça un peu
bizarre de le principe quoi mais bon
après pourquoi pas quoi ouais en fait ça
favorise quand même pas mal
en gros c'est que ouais tu enlèves de
l'incertitude en faisant ça
et bon en fait dans le sport justement
enfin on aime bien que des fois soit pas
sur Le Mercier pourquoi jouer quoi
c'est genre tu as l'impression que tu as
envie de toujours voir une finale
Carlson Naka
tu rentres à la maison quoi et ça permet
de continuer un petit peu le tournoi
quoi
et puis pourquoi pas
mais il faudrait que je puisse comparer
parce qu'en fait chaque c'est une
formule qui n'utilise pas mal dans les
dans les jeux vidéo et voir eux qu'elle
leur formule pourquoi ils font ça à quel
moment la durée des tournois etc quoi
donc
en fait j'ai pas trop de référentiel
j'ai que les échecs en fait
donc tu vois j'ai du mal à dire mais en
soi je suis pas choqué par la formule
mais je trouve pas ça génial non plus
enfin en fait je pourquoi pas quoi
mais ouais génial il faut faire ça tout
le temps c'est fantastique non je trouve
que c'est intéressant puis même le fait
de mettre l'Armageddon aux enchères je
trouve que c'est aussi sympa
psychologie il y a un peu de
je sais pas comment expliquer c'est
voilà et là pareil tu peux là par
exemple tu es éliminé mais tu peux avec
l'élimination on va voir un peu de
chance ou pas dans les tirages
tu vois tu as une deuxième chance c'est
parce qu'il se passe et malgré tout ça
Nakamura
donc
après ça paraitre
[Musique]
donc mais voilà c'est un format qui est
différent des autres en fait ça c'est
cool parce que c'est souvent les échecs
en termes d'événements se sont pareils
parce que une fois que tu perds tu vois
le speed chest par exemple
quand tu joues Naka ça va le temps
j'aime pas le speechasse la formule
parce que
tu te souviens de match
Nakamura contre ouifane
oui c'est un score je crois qu'elle a
marqué deux points
de mémoire
pendant 3 heures elle a marqué deux
points donc je sais pas si c'était
victoire ou de nuit j'en sais même plus
et il y avait deux points marqués et lui
il avait une vingtaine
ok bon ben même tu prends 6-07 tu vois
c'est fini
c'est qu'en plus il faut que les parties
elles sont trop enchaînées donc un mot
en fait tu peux plus souffler
pour les joueurs et de deux ça peut vite
être très intéressant parce que s'il y a
quatre cinq six points d'écart tu
reviens pas donc en fait tu es obligé de
jouer longtemps et le dernier cas de
figure aussi à signaler c'est que ça
permet de jouer la pendule
gérer et du coup je vous définir le foot
toujours à poser complètement nul
pendant 200 coups
mouvant et puis en gagnant du temps
après machin et
perdre vite ou en 150 coups c'est pareil
en fait normalement
c'est pas de prix à perdre lentement
bien sûr bien sûr et
en fait il y a trop de choses qui vont
pas pour moi là-dedans après c'est le
format qui veut et du coup les joueurs
profitent du format
par rapport au fair-play etc là de côté
pour profiter de ça moi je suis papa
mais bon mais c'est vrai que par exemple
un truc de 7 c'était pas mal et en fait
on voit plus trop trop quand même de
nouvelles formules qu'on attend d'échec
et c'est vrai que c'est appréciable de
voir de nouveaux trucs et au moins on
essaye tu vois et cette idée de faire
des bah tu vois double double
élimination bah écoute pourquoi pas
c'est joli parce que c'est ouvert
mes cavaliers si tu prends il y en a du
couloir
d'ailleurs un coup un coup brillant de
la partie blanc qui en fait va contrôler
la classe B1 et une fois que tu prends
en G6 en H4 et du couloir parce que je
contrôle les deux cases avec avec les
Blancs jolies et du coup bah j'arrive
devient un peu un peu fragile et ouais
c'est devenu chaud donc H3 voilà donc si
je prends là il y a match
très très pénible
[Musique]
j'y crois pas trop mais à voir
mais bon
dernier coup de vent de Forest c'est
cavalier FTIs coût brillant meilleur
coup et coup brillant quoi
avec des attaques de maths même
tu vois imaginons je fais un coup bah
écoute peut-être que c'est le meilleur
coup quoi
je me lasse tout quoi
mais peut-être que le mieux ça allait
donner la dame contre la tour et du coup
Carolin j'ai l'impression était gourmand
avec son cahier H4 parce que je crois
qu'il pouvait répéter
le fait que il avait les 6 qui avait
l'âge 4
j'ai raté l'idée parce que là
mais bon après ok c'est pas pour c'est
la partie
mais car voilà il a quand même de jouer
deux parties plus un Armageddon donc
tu peux dire oui bon il s'est chauffé
qui est pas faux mais aussi
il s'est aussi
un petit peu fatigué et
forest qui est d'ailleurs j'ai pas
changé les noms
c'est quand même à quelque part logique
il y a une prime à celui qui parle plus
tard possible
dans le circuit principal
a perdu dans la finale des vainqueurs
entre guillemets donc il est assez
invaincu un jour plus que Carmona et
donc ce petit avantage par rapport aux
autres d'arriver pour la finale des
perdants entre guillemets tout frais et
comme ça faudra cette avantage de de pas
avoir à jouer aujourd'hui et d'être
tranquille demain et d'avoir le droit de
perdre une fois donc il y a quand même
cette
je pense normal quoi oui bah c'est comme
avant
le match je pense tu as quand même
quelques privilèges d'avoir bien joué
une
forteresse peut avoir lieu ici
je crois que c'en est une mais bon après
elle est blanc peuvent jouer longtemps
il risque rien quoi donc on peut un peu
essayer et puis voir si on monte à la
pousse un peu les pions démolir un peu
l'abri du roi noir mais le problème en
fait c'est que en fait même si tu
arrives à f4g5 a avancer faire des
échecs et que les Nord perdent leurs
fous contre ton pion G2 ça sera quand
même nul quoi puis on fêter la tour
et donc du coup je vois pas trop ce
qu'on peut obtenir en fait
si je permets le fond
la tête si tu fais foutranger 4 c'est
nul d'ailleurs
en fait alors je sais qu'il y a une nul
c'était si je perds ça ça
ça et que bon je mange bon tout est pion
ou même juste FG et après je mets un
tour en G6 je fais super
avec madame qui a une histoire mais je
crois qu'avec le pion en F7 il y a nul
comme ça donc bon là on a quand même
deux pions et un four en plus je pense
qu'on est assez large pour défendre
cette nul ce qui est incroyable parce
que Ben matériellement on voit quand
même qu'on a une dame contre juste
tu cumules les deux tu as une dame quoi
c'est ça
tu peux rien faire en fait
parce que beaucoup de gens pensent
qu'une dame c'est trop fort qu'on a une
dame enfin une dame de plus on s'est
gagné mais en fait des points vous avez
5 + 3,8 ici contre une dame qui est en
vaut 9 donc quasiment équivalent mais en
fait avec une dame on fait rien quand on
a qu'une seule dame et les pions bah on
peut rien faire le roi elle va essayer
mais bon le roi il va être coupé par la
tour et par les pièces et ça c'est une
forteresse alors une forteresse c'est
quoi c'est quand je censé avoir une
position avec avantage de matériel mais
qu'en fait ça avec mes pièces noires je
vais réussir à à faire une forteresse ça
veut dire que je vais blinder et que tu
pourras jamais passer en fait j'attends
j'attends et je passe
et c'est la partie plus forteresse
et là normalement ça va être nul bon
après enfin de Forest il a la raison de
jouer il a plus de temps la pendule
c'est lui qui Adam quand même
non mais faudrait que son roi c'était
les portes en 7
[Musique]
et tu commenceras sur FC et peut-être
dans mes fuites et je sais pas quoi et
encore je suis même pas sûr ça suffirait
mais ça serait bon signe mais juste ça
va jamais arriver quoi
parce que
il va faire tourger 5 il va te couper la
route
je suis évidemment placé avec ma tour
ici parce que tout droit passera jamais
ici et si tu penses que tu en es
toujours G4 donc
je crois que c'est d'être drôle
à faire
et puis là il y a pas de blague parce
qu'il y a un rajout de temps trois
secondes parcours donc
[Musique]
priori
un trop gros cadeau
qui a fait une série de coups assez
incroyable très jolie qui a qui a failli
mater le roi de kerwana et ben écoute
malgré tout ben ça suffit pas quoi toi
pour battre un jour comme caravane
quand même un poussin un peu hein
déjà c'est dur d'être mieux contre eux
qui même quand tu es mieux bon bah ouais
même quand
ils vont te rendre fou et si jamais tu
arrives à passer outre ça
être sur des défenses incroyables
c'est ouf ils ont des ressources
[Musique]
un petit peu de
ah mais bien sûr enfin il tente il tente
il fait un truc intéressant j'aime bien
j'aime bien la tentative
bon je commence à
[Musique]
un petit truc un peu F5
je sais pas comment ça va jouer
bon il va faire des va-et-vient sur la
colonne
[Musique]
j'ai pas le temps de faire une menace
et puis maintenant que j'ai bien bloqué
le plongée ouais c'est juste nul en fait
quand même c'était pas fait d'avance il
est quand même arrivé à faire ça mais
c'est pas ça et nul nul nul signé
ok nul et bon bah Fabiano avec les
Blancs on va tenter de gagner pour
rejoindre la finale ouais donc là encore
une seule partie donc si dans la
prochaine partie donc avec les Blancs
s'il y a un résultat favorable pour un
des joueurs et ben ce genre de la grande
finale contre abusottov en cas d'égalité
il y aura un match des partages
Armageddon avec enchères comme on a vu
avec Jules même principe voilà entre les
deux joueurs donc voilà
on se dit de pause
[Musique]
et
on se retrouve d'ici 5 minutes et puis
et puis pour la pour la suite de la
compétition à tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et nous sommes revenus alors la partie
qui vient à peine de commencer je vais
vous mettre le score le score à jour
donc on a encore grande Forrest en bas
avec les Noirs donc je lui ai dit que
c'était son joujou qui voulait qu'il
gagne donc on va le supporter jusqu'au
bout
alors je vais vous mettre juste les
points qui vont
qui vont avec
et j'ai mis des points car voilà
pourquoi j'ai un truc bizarre
et je ne sais pas pourquoi
est-ce que j'ai une sorte des miroirs tu
vois le score de
je vois rien en fait mais
du coup j'en ai fait miroir on dirait un
[Musique]
un miroir comme ça
au pire on peut reconnaître le 1 quoi
de toute façon il a 0,5 donc il a pas un
on espère qu'il est qu'il a pas gagné
comme ça on va pas ce problème on va lui
et donc c'est marrant qu'en fait les
0,5 il est à l'envers c'est trop bizarre
quoi j'ai un problème
mais là c'est chelou j'ai l'impression
que j'ai un problème de j'ai une idée
pour toi mais un X
tu es XX ça va et la boîte à l'envers ça
sera toujours un X ouais
[Musique]
je sais pas
même là en fait c'est marrant
le truc qui m'annonce
et là par contre
je vais mettre des petites je pense que
tu es un génie merci et puis ça m'a
l'air bien en espérant que et si ils
font nul et ben je marque XX
X
ou l parce que ça ressemble à un et à
l'envers ça marchera
[Musique]
bref cette partie c'était quoi comme
ouverture
anti-barlinoise donc espagnol à mon avis
mais je sais pas
OK
Jul il a perdu en ramage
donc
[Musique]
il n'a pas la première gagné la deuxième
et malheureusement la dernière il a
perdu la succombé
et c'était chaud en cabane qui a pas
trompé
sur intéressante
plutôt mieux blanc moi j'aime bien les
blancs
sur le renard et puis donc la présence
des fous de l'Europe ça renforce cette
envie d'attaquer parce que chaque fou
peut pas croiser le chemin de l'autre
donc les blancs vont pouvoir attaquer
les cases noires à souhait et c'est pour
ça que c'est bien d'avoir l'initiative
quand il y a ce rapport matériel
pourquoi pas j'aime beaucoup les blancs
franchement vraiment beaucoup
je pense que c'est une belle réussite de
la part de caravanes dans cette partie
là
belle réussite dans la dans la
préparation
il est un peu une position où il peut
mettre la pression clairement avant de
forêt avant de Forest hier qui a trouvé
des ressources incroyables avant une
partie contre
abusottarov une partie avec Kevin on l'a
quasiment enterré et en fait quatre tous
les coups
pas évident et il a réussi à se défendre
c'était incroyable
ah oui alors l'appel va se couper ok on
fait quoi dans
le raccroche ok vas-y c'est que
comme on a eu vu et ben on avait on
avait une réunion de groupe elles sont
limitées donc je raccroche
il considère que c'est c'est un groupe
donc voilà
salut Arnaud
un jour ça
[Musique]
à la fin
on contrôle tout et on sent que c'est
vraiment une poubelle tu vas jamais le
manger en fait tu vas juste mettre la
mettre ses pions
[Musique]
ok donc tu avais 5 n'était pas possible
et donc il a quand même essayer à
proposer de faire cette faute
donc sur case sur case blanche du coup
il a fait à 4 histoire de pouvoir faire
à 5 chasser le qui est B6 donc c'est un
peu le même thème dont on est parlé tout
à l'heure avec les cavaliers en B3 G3
sauf là c'est côté noir donc ici
et je pense aussi son idée c'est comme
ça sur
ce pion prend le 4 il pourra prendre du
cavalier peut-être sauter en C5 ou
quelque chose comme ça
quelle couleur bah là je préfère les
blancs je pense que tout le monde prend
les blancs ici une position quand même
on en a parlé tout à l'heure tu as les
bonnes pièces et puis elle est noire ont
du mal à bouger un prise comme tu l'as
dit avec ses cinq partout
pendant que les Noirs prennent beaucoup
de mal à s'organiser donc là je sais pas
quoi y réfléchit moi j'aurais pu trouver
203 réfléchir mais je crois qu'il a joué
à 4 ah pardon
j'avais vu qu'il avait joué
qu'il avait joué donc à 4 oui donc à 4
du coup
tu vas avoir envie de faire de faire un
5 et puis envoyer une qui est lancé vite
il sera pas très beau
empêcher et oui l'idée de mettre le
camelot sur un dessin quand on a parlé
de ça essayer mais bon même si quelque
chose
qui pose quand même beaucoup de
problèmes
bah écoute c'est une question de travail
pour les pour les blancs je pense que
pas bien d'autres qui qui doit être à
satisfait de la pollution qu'il a obtenu
la dame en 17 c'était pas du tout
intuitif du genre d'y penser même mais
en fait ok pas mal
le score XX alors 0,5 05 05 05 mais
c'est sûr que si je le mets sur une
autre si je change de
scène
des points là
donc je sais pas pourquoi
Arnaud du coup il me dit que c'est dans
le cahier est-ce que tu l'as reçu alors
ou tu me le dis comme ça et tu l'as reçu
ben écoute merci
j'espère qu'il plaira et qu'il aidera de
faire progresser et apprendre deux trois
trucs sur un peu l'histoire des échecs
et des records et des anecdotes quoi
je vous ai mis le truc sauf que là
maintenant il y a tous les noms qui sont
à l'envers qui sont à l'envers mais au
moins je vais ça je vais vous le changer
hein
au moins vous aurez des vraies scores
mais ça marche j'ai beaucoup apprécié
ton idée DX mais au moins je pense aussi
je mixe tout le temps vont me demander à
chaque fois le score en plus les X je
veux dire c'est même pas une idée
saugrenu c'est
aux échecs de match on met des X quoi
donc en plus
c'est un truc de bricoles mais qui
marche quoi
est-il encore possible de gagner avec
les Noirs tu veux dire quoi plus
générale ou cette partie là bon
d'ailleurs je vais répondre oui dans les
deux cas de figure comme ça pas de
suspense
ici ils sont plutôt moins bien les Noirs
mais écoute tu as rien au moins en
termes de matériel
l'adversaire peut encore faire une
erreur ou quoi donc c'est toujours
possible
et sinon en général bah oui oui bien sûr
en plus c'est plus agréable je pense
avoir les blancs dans une partie comme
ça où on peut quand même plus en voyant
donc
on voit mieux comment on peut attaquer
et donc là cavalier 8 oui on va pas
arrêter du BSI c'est cavaliers qui
pourra abandonner sans voir revenir sur
une case plus sympa et en plus il a
empêché le soir de se faire croquer le
pion à 7
avec les Blancs s'il a envie je trouve
pas ça bête ça pique c'est un peu B6 et
le jour quand même et ben j'aurais quand
même obtenu la colonne A sur le bord
exactement
alors après bon on est obligé de recul
en rêve de c'était pas notre choix idéal
mais bon c'est la vie quoi
je bloque la tour en P4 on va chercher
et ici on va se prendre des fourchettes
donc c'est pas forcément ce qu'il veut
alors est-ce que ce que je peux juste
faire un coup de style tout reste 4
bêtise qui va arriver avec la menace
[Musique]
bon après oui on n'est pas non plus
écrasant dans la position
en fait à haut niveau avec les notes et
content de réaliser c'est ton objectif
mais les joueurs avec les blancs ils
essayent eux d'être mieux quitte à
prendre quelques risques et justement tu
peux d'autant plus contrer et donc en
pratique il y a assez enfin ça peut très
bien avec les Noirs
aussi que même plus la cadence est
rapide
plus en fait de manière générale les
blancs et les Noirs gagnent en fait il y
a plus de résultats
décisifs parce que c'est moins précis
c'est moins précis on joue moins bien on
fait des erreurs et puis c'est normal
après dans les temps appartient très
souvent qu'on aura gagné aussi beaucoup
moins que l'inverse mais ça arrive
encore le jeu est pas terminé et puis
c'est vers ça
donc bien sûr je pense que c'est sûr le
score des blancs est quand même bien
supérieur au score de noir
mais ça surtout dans les dans les bons
joueurs dans les joueurs de l'élite
parce qu'après vraiment tu prends des
amateurs je pense que ça nul
franchement
on est genre de club blanc noir c'est
pareil
c'est pareil
parce que et puis on connaît pas les
ouvertures enfin c'est pas c'est
différent
mais
[Musique]
voilà donc du coup voilà très bon à la
question quoi
que cette
il veut peut-être rebondir F5 attention
attention
[Musique]
que les problèmes d'ailleurs j'avais
même pas vu ton premier recettes qui
était
un vrai gros problème j'ai même pas vu
que c'était possible donc il a joué il a
joué F6 pour protéger
noir pour faire un mur au foie de verse
et reprendre le contrôle un peu de ces
caisses qu'il ne peut pas contrôler avec
son fou donc c'est pas bête
on voit mal comment on attaque en fait
il arrivait à rétablir un peu la
situation
des Noirs dans la base de données un
parti entre
de nul et deux victoires blanches et
autres questions que je l'avais du coup
si tu peux est-ce que c'est inclut
toutes les parties quelle que soit les
cadences et les partitions Internet et
des bits ou c'est que des parties lentes
parce qu'il y a quand même c'est vrai
qu'il y a quand même pas mal de parties
de ce que les tournois sur Internet
j'aime pas moi
j'aime pas
mais bon tu dis ouais
je veux pas cette partie moi je vais
faire moi ça quoi
le tri par cadence il devrait faire
cette option
non mais en fait en fait c'est à toi de
virer tu vois tu
regardes que des parties qui sont oui
mais après ça
non mais ça m'avait il y a pas trop
longtemps
puis je vois les parties je regarde ils
vont jouer
partie 2 et en fait j'avais même pas
trouvé une partie normale quoi je
vraiment j'en ai marre moi je clique je
ferme
ah oui
arrêtez avec ça et en plus et en plus il
y a beaucoup de monde
qui moi j'en connais un mais des gens
qui m'aiment
s'échangent les pseudos pour
pour dire ah pour truquer les bases
pour pas pour essayer de tromper les
gens lors de la
content que je suis pas content que les
parties Internet soit disponibles quoi
qu'il en soit en fait non moi j'aime pas
non plus
de streamer je mets toutes les parties
tout ce que je joue sur pièce club et
ben c'est mon nom donc tout le monde
peut le voir et en plus dès que je suis
intéressé
dur quand tu joues normalement bon bah
en jouant un sous répertoire bonne
chance donc en fait aucune chance
donc tous les deux je vous laisse 5 il
est échangé aussi
comme ça on prend échec en Détroit avec
une petite double attaque sympa et c'est
pas bête parce que ça enlève ce pion
c'est 5 qui prenait des cases au four
salut donner plus d'espace plus de
diagonale pour bouger
donc
les blancs
qui peut créer pas mal de dégâts moi
j'aimerais bien ici mettre le mettre le
point B2
et là sur le long terme avec le
vis-à-vis sur le roi
il peut y avoir des petites tactiques un
jour même à base de ce cadre bouche ton
cavalier il te reprend M6 il peut y
avoir un truc en l'air un peu de partout
et puis tu peux consacrer aussi
j'ai 4 non non mais je veux dire
passer t'occuper un peu les Noirs
mais dans l'idée je pense que mettre
aussi ça va clairement être c'est pas
mal de stratégies
4 gagner un temps foulard gagner un
temps et tu vois
même dame j'ai 6 c'est clairement
h6 il y a plein plein d'idées qui
peuvent arriver en tout cas ici pour les
blancs j'aime beaucoup la petite
carbonara je trouve qu'en pratique c'est
c'est pas facile en plus ça peut être
une dernière partie parce que je vous
rappelle que s'il y a un résultat
favorable pour l'un ou l'autre et ben ce
jour-là ira en finale contre
en cas de nul il y aura un magasin
et ouais
du coup on dit du coup je peux contre
qui
bah je joue pas en fait
il y a du coup les meilleurs est-ce que
je dois répertoire bah bon déjà il
travaille beaucoup plus ils ont ils ont
facile ils ont très large
et donc j'imagine dans répertoire
officiel entre guillemets et
des trucs un peu poubelles mais déjà pas
mal qui peuvent jouer
un peu partout alors ça leur va
tellement jouer tellement toujours en
fait que
[Musique]
en fait c'est plus un problème chez
amateurs ou chez les joueurs
comme toi et moi quoi
en fait on a on a on peut avoir
plusieurs répertoires mais jamais aussi
fort que principal
et soit on joue le principal et bon bah
du coup bah on dévoile tout soit on joue
un truc
qu'on joue plus qu'on qui est pas super
bon tu vois et au final ben on voit
complètement et on est un peu handicapé
sur la partie terrain après t'as pas
oublié que c'est un tournoi online et
puis au final
l'intérêt enfin je pense que toi comme
moi quand on
veut pas pour gagner non
autant
oui mais quand tu joues tu as envie de
faire un truc tu as envie en fait si tu
joues enfin déjà que c'est tueur de base
mais que tu joues sur des balles dans le
pied ah oui non mais voilà quand tu
joues essayez de dire bon
de faire un tournant après le gagner
le top 10 c'est très souvent représenté
mondialistes qui jouent à chaque fois et
le niveau monstrueux quoi donc
nous
on a un peu plus de mal de faire des
pertes sur une partie on peut battre un
gros joueur mais après sur un tournant
entier oui bah sur un tournoi c'est
régularité le problème
mais
donc oui en plus voilà notre problème à
nous en gros donc on a répertoire plus
restreint et de deux on fait d'autres
trucs à côté enfin tu stream tu fais des
cours
moi je stream pas vraiment mais
j'interviens souvent sur sur la chaîne
de Kevin et et ici et je fais des cours
aussi et puis j'écris etc et donc en
fait je crois que le peu de temps qu'on
a pour travailler un peu pour nous les
échecs c'est pas pour aller jouer sur un
blitz et dévoiler et perdre des heures
là dessus quoi bien sûr donc en fait
c'est juste ça le problème aussi quoi
mais en fait j'aurais dix heures par
jour à consacre aux échecs
ouais varier de répertoire et jouer des
trucs pas mal en title ça me poserait
pas de souci mais là en fait
une heure par semaine avec consacrée
c'est déjà beaucoup et bah du coup je
peux pas quoi
de révéler des secrets de prépa ou des
trucs
enfin en fait les infos gratuites quoi
je vais la garder au chaud quoi
[Musique]
dans la partie pour le gain du title
mais
tu vois ça n'arrivera pas quoi c'est bon
pour pour gagner ta gueule quoi
jules a été en demi-finale de la poule
des parents d'ailleurs je vous ai pas
mis ça un jour aussi
était en demi-finale de la poule des
perdants
Fabiano donc je termine quatrième du
tournoi belle belle performance
et là du coup
en gros ouais c'est un format spécial on
va pas le répéter tout le temps parce
que il y a des gens qui doivent être là
depuis le début il peut pas nous
entendre toujours dire la même truc mais
le vainqueur de ce match ce qualifie
pour la finale demain
il y a quelqu'un qui les attend déjà et
ce quelqu'un sait d'où ça torof
en gros d'ailleurs c'est marrant parce
que
il a il a éliminé
[Musique]
les deux joueurs que tu en finale ok
donc la finale des perdants sponsoris
tous les deux et d'ailleurs Emma parce
que Jules qui a joué aussi la finale
enfin la demi-finale contre Fabiano en
fait les trois joueurs ont été sortis
par par lui
pour la finale peu importe lequel
et ben il faudra battre deux fois par
contre pour gagner le match prendre un
premier set pour que vous ayez chacun
une défaite en tournoi et gagner le
deuxième set alors j'ai envie de dire
que qu'ici karena il peut mettre la
pression mais si il est mieux tu vois je
sais pas si tu fais un tour B5 qui fout
des quatre par exemple essayer de
par derrière par des 7 B7 ou D8 B8 et
oui oui enfin il est mieux là après je
sais pas à quel point tu peux vraiment
gagner ou faut mettre la tour c'est les
Noirs ils veulent peut-être à même qu'il
y a des trois ou un e6c5 ou quoi mais
clairement c'est les blancs qui ont
toutes les chances ici parce que le
tandem tofu c'est mieux qu'un tandem de
tour cavalier ça marche bien ensemble
et là on a un pion passé potentiel à
l'aile dame avec A et B
A et B n'importe quoi avec BC contre B
alors que les Noirs leur majorité allait
le roi en fait elle est moins dangereuse
on a déjà le rend en face donc même si
un pion passé bon de toute façon on a le
droit devant et on va pas les laisser
faire et ok on se stoppera le pion donc
tous ces avantages cumulés ça fait ça
fait qu'on préfère les blancs mais voilà
presque concrètement ça va suffire à
voir parce que là voilà il ramène son
camion aussi donc direction C5 où il va
à la fois attaquer la tour et puis en B3
et aussi privé de la caisse B7 peut-être
que tu en D7 n'était pas méga précis
pour le coup
mais bon après c'est toujours ça la
difficulté aux échecs
et le coup et en fait c'est vrai que
c'est pas trop B7 et c'est 5 va attaquer
les deux pièces
avant qu'on la Tour Eiffel peut-être ça
c'était un peu plus malin
et maintenant
tu fais ça et ben j'ai le temps de voir
les choses en fait il y a une petite
erreur de la part des blancs la
réalisation tous les quatre il est
maintenant empêché qu'elle va laisser 5
mais ouais bon enfin en fait il a encore
une tour plus active et un roi qui du
coup va peut-être pouvoir monter plus
facilement
en fait en gros j'aimerais bien le temps
de faire étorber 7 et monter loin mais
tant pis 7 il va y avoir tout réussi
sous forme coupé donc il a fait tour des
cinq
par là je pense et voir un peu peut-être
même monter le roi là mais en fait il va
ils vont changer ça et ça final qui est
nul quand même
déjà proposé quoi ouais bon il va jouer
parce que
là mais voilà jouer mais ça va faire nul
sans aucun doute ça on est d'accord on
va mettre la tour ici on va pousser le
pion lui va mettre son roi ici il va
attendre
et
puis ça devrait faire nul sans trop de
problèmes je pense pour vente forest ici
qui va réussir à tenir il a raison
je pense assez vite
donc toi chaque là maintenant attention
il donne G7 ouais mais en fait tu peux
donner j'ai
peut-être et quand même la tenir quoi
mais en plus j'ai du F1 qui doit tenir
parce que par exemple sur ton projet 7
ah bon il joue c'est 5
bon en même temps c'est vrai pas
s'envoler c'est pas bête
et là les noirs du coup faut trouver un
coup ou
en fait on aimerait passer notre tour
ouais
ça change que
non ça va pas très mal en F5 en fait
6 mais je suis pas sûr c'est suffisait à
perdre
ça ça et sur C7 droite un peu coupée
certes
est-ce que je peux faire un gros comme
G5
et ben pourquoi pas et essayer de te
dire bah tiens si tu manges
en passant pour apprendre et ça va et là
je me lasse quand même de manger ton
pain là c'est pas con
il l'a pas fait
le repousser un petit peu comme ça
donc de la finale après Laura c'est ça
non mais c'est clair le gagnant de de ce
match clairement
clairement battre un doux c'est clair
après il est vraiment il est vraiment
fort
il est assez impressionnant mais je
l'avais déjà vu la dernière fois là il
est battu Maxime oui
je sais pas on n'est pas trop suivi les
trucs ça peut être médiatisé mais
il avait hyper bien joué déjà
[Musique]
avec le tien
dans les paramètres qui se met en veille
je sais pas bon c'est pas grave
[Musique]
je suis assez réactif
G4 et
un moment donné on va devoir échanger le
pion c'est contre le pionger et il va y
avoir un roi F4 pour prendre les 7 tours
F4 et peut-être la tour qui va venir
manger à h6 mais je comprends rien et
que Laura blanc
je pense qu'il y a absolument zéro
chance de gain
en plus ça va plus t'aider absolument
toutes les chances toutes les chances de
faire un résultat parce que
tout le temps des araignées donc
pas tant que ça
c'est juste pour moi
mais
non non ça fait nul direct voilà ça fait
nul mais je veux dire oui non avant si
on regarde là on voit que
tire disent dans le chat a essayé de
mettre le bracket on n'a pas de trucs
barquette par contre moi j'en ai un vous
le montrer si vous voulez braquer il est
il est ici et donc là on voit un que la
finale des loosers prime c'est les
joueurs qui ont déjà perdu un match rien
de se jouer il y a un on va tester
maintenant au départage à l'armadou qui
va arriver et le gagnant dans le magasin
va rencontrer à des autorov pour la
grande finale qui se jouera demain à
partir de 17 heures
donc dans les matchs
en deux entre ou en quatre parties c'est
4 ça revient 4 demain
ça fait 5 mais s'il y a quatre parties
qui a 2 il joue quand même il est pas
quand même champion du coup
non mais c'est à quatre parties
champion ok en fait si je fais deux
Carmageddon et que je gagne un magasin
non mais en fait en gros oui mais c'est
moi qui croyais que enfin qu'en gros le
mec qui revenait était en me swing sur
le match enquête party mais pas du tout
en fait non non non il doit gagner le
match peu importe comment oui voilà il
gagne 2,5
non Carolin a besoin de
Abdou Vincent non tu vois dans la pointe
de gagnants il y a eu que un seul
c'était Moussa colors et après Nakamura
sur roujanon ou star Shimano caravane
nature rouge à Londres
en fait
il y a eu trois ingrédients dans ce
tournoi et tu en as fait deux déjà
donc demain peut-être tu vas continuer
sans t'annoncer et donc je pense que les
appareils en tout cas les les
paris les enchères des joueurs vont de
te présenter d'ici
quelques instants alors là je les ai pas
encore
je vais voir je vais ouvrir mon petit
mon petit slack mais normalement c'est
toujours
comme ça non ça c'était pas ça
parce qu'il a écrit
à 19h05
c'est bizarre
ok bon là j'ai pas encore j'ai pas
encore ça on va avoir en tout cas les
les
paris très bientôt vous savez que pour
l'Armageddon il va en fait les joueurs
vont écrire à l'arbitre
avec des enchères de temps pour savoir
qui va prendre le blanc et qui va
prendre
les Noirs donc généralement on reçoit
les
enchères d'ici quelques minutes
pendant la pause c'est une anecdote sur
le deux frères
en ne prononce pas la rond de famille de
la même façon
sérieux c'est bizarre
[Rires]
que que le prénom ça fait qu'ils
utilisent un autre accent après plus
tonique antonique plus si plus ça je
sais pas donc il y a des trucs pour dire
Télénet de la famille ou je sais pas
mais en fait
je sais pas en tout cas bon tu as Jordan
et l'autre frère comment il s'appelle
déjà Lucas
Lucas Lucas
qui participe au tournoi chargent en ce
moment qui est dur
issue là c'est fini en fait
mais
c'est trop fort contre
le tournoi et pourtant c'est un joueur
qui a quasiment 2006 quoi
le monstre quoi le tournoi
c'est horrible je vais voir si on a des
résultats
enfin j'ai pas du tout suivi
par hasard
peut-être j'avais regardé mais j'ai pas
vu la dernière partie j'ai vu la
pareillement
j'arrive pas à retrouver le tournoi
je regarderai plus tard
non c'est pas fini il y a l'Armageddon
qui va commencer
une seule partie en attendant jusqu'à
quelle démarche et aussi de savoir
les temps de chaque joueur du carton par
un S et
un V
dans un S ça se prononce quasiment comme
un F
donc c'est ça c'est votre prénom ou ta
peine parce que je pense
c'est marrant quoi
trop dur pour moi trop dur
salut
à vous tous
allez on attend avec impatience
le tirage au sort mais les temps de nos
joueurs
et
on espère d'avoir très bientôt cette
fois arrivé bientôt là à partir
d'ailleurs pendant la pendant ce
temps-là je vais vous montrer vous savez
que le Magnus a un nouveau partenariat
et ça il faut que je vous le montre donc
je vais vous le montrer du coup je l'ai
sans l'autre scène je crois je vérifiez
juste pour pour le truc
vous avez ici
hop petite photo de Magnus avec sa
chaussure Puma d'ailleurs
en Puma donc sa nouvelle partenariat
humain avec des belles chaussures et la
chaussure ici
franchement c'est moi j'aime bien fou
rire
tu verras sur le stream d'ici quelques
secondes vous savez qu'on a une minute
de décalage avec le chat
mais voilà donc si vous voulez chaque je
vous recommande d'acheter
ses chaussures des chaussures d'échecs
qui sont PUMA
avec un peu de chance voilà vous aurez
comme Magnus dans la prochaine partie
moi sur le vent comme ça j'achète direct
tu te sens tout de suite
[Musique]
j'avais vu hier dans le chat on avait eu
des trucs et apparemment cette chanson
pour bien qu'on comprenne
c'est pas mal ou quoi
genre 2 Jordan forest
c'est peut-être pire que l'allemand en
fait quelque part c'était dur d'imaginer
que c'était possible mais c'est un peu
le même genre en fait
tu appelles un bras style j'ai envie de
dire
alors attends
9-49,4 et moi j'ai pas le temps et
normalement les temps je les ai quand
même sur slack
et
ah ça y est j'ai le temps
où ça s'est joué à 3 secondes ok 3
secondes
forest 956 carvana donc Forest a gagné
l'enchère et a donc les blancs
gagner en fait on sait pas si on sait
pas vraiment si les gens gagnent ou pas
leur chef
53 non 26 non en fait quand tu quand tu
ah non en fait c'est quand tu
le montreras avec 953 j'imagine
normalement mais alors là sur l'autre
sur le truc il y a marqué
9-53956 et il y a marqué van forest
choisi les blancs
je viens de de comprendre ça avec toi
avant c'était jamais ce cas le joueur
qui avait qui avait mis plus bas avec
toujours
avec toujours toujours les noirs
ça peut être il peut y avoir il peut y
avoir
et avoir plusieurs règles au courant de
celle-là et donc en tout cas en tout cas
dans la partie 15 minutes pour vendre
forest avec les Blancs contre 9 56 pour
carbonara avec les noirs
et
en cas de nul en cas de match nul et ben
c'est noir qui gagne et qui passerait en
finale contre abdos
et donc voilà donc il y a pas
d'incrément c'est du chaos c'est du
chaos clair
et la partie qui va commencer un achetez
pas encore mais dès qu'on l'a
dès qu'on l'a
retarder
dès qu'on l'a on vous on vous l'envoie
et contre juste les quoi rester 9 58 et
la 9 56 c'est pareil 2 secondes près et
Carole a quand même qui est là depuis le
début ça fait quasiment 4 heures qu'on
est là et après tu vois si tombe 2
secondes contre 0 on dirait c'était tout
à fait pareil c'était malin
c'était malin
donc on a encore les blancs donc non
c'est pardon c'est qui a des blancs donc
je vais devoir encore vous
plonger ça
donc je vais aller partir ici je crois
qu'en bas on reste à les blancs
et on garde le petit x
changer de
l ou le
juste minuscule ou le I majuscule ça
fera un partout quoi je vais essayer
partout quoi
[Rires]
à 7 ne marche pas
on m'a dit de faire deux points
dans ce match
et ça va commencer enfin un instant
la prochaine mesdames et messieurs yes
ça va commencer
alors est-ce qu'on a la partie non j'ai
pas encore la partie
tous les jours sont pas encore l'avant
de Forest ça je trouve assez marrant
parce que tu vois il y a quand même deux
nuls et
de prendre le long pour gagner
c'est quand même assez osé
[Musique]
les avoir
il a pris des blancs alors ouais parce
que peut-être qu'il s'est dit
950 enfin je sais pas moi non peut-être
il se dit bon j'étais 5 minutes d'avance
à la pendule
bah ça vaut quelque chose 5 minutes
et les blancs c'est quand même un
avantage de temps tu peux plus mieux
jouer plus réfléchir etc par contre en
cas de nul
juste
un petit qui avait juste la partie
d'avant
moi je sais pas du tout ce que je
prendrais
mon avis je prends les blancs
[Musique]
autant que j'ai une chance à jouer un
truc déséquilibré avec la pendule et à
tout jouer tempo et le flag en fait
quand elle est noire contre lui
j'ai pas de temps j'arrête pas de
position j'aurais rien
donc moi c'est très clair en fait dans
ce cas de figure mais
pas selon quel adversaire j'ai à voir
mais
après je sais pas j'ai pas les stats des
Armageddon comme ça
mais je sais quand j'avais joué un
tournoi
c'était éliminatoire et j'avais une
armée à jouer j'avais choisi les blancs
mais c'était genre 6,5 ou je sais plus
quoi c'est différent là du temps tu as
plus de temps donc là je sais pas avec
ça donne envie d'un cadre de prendre les
Noirs en fait quand tu appuies il y a de
temps [__]
ça va et
[Musique]
il a rien choisi en fait c'est que juste
il a gagné en charge à 53 et voilà
on avait bien compris sur l'autre
l'autre il y a eu une mauvaise entente
mais regarde
regarde
tu peux le fermer ce truc en fait c'est
quoi nous pas besoin de nous
on savait que le joueur qui est plus bas
avaler noir mais comme il a dit qu'il
fallait laisser des blancs peut-être
qu'on a pas mal compris mais en fait et
bon on a tout compris mieux que
et c'est pour ça que j'avais mal fait
donc du coup bah les points sont pas
bons parce que la minute scène je vais
vous remettre un petit
et là on va être sur une scène qui
marche
très très vite en face mais j'aime bien
en fait les chances de Kawana parce que
tu joues cavalier contre le mauvais fou
entre guillemets entre guillemets fou et
tu peux travailler longtemps j'ai
l'impression que même si tu te fais
réellement égaliser ce qui est pas
encore le cas il est objectivement mieux
un petit peu
ce sera pas une tête drôle ça sera que
ça joue et donc
c'est agréable en fait tu m'as un
cavalier là où là et tu peux jouer F4 et
tu peux essayer de mettre une tour là je
le B4 même plus la tour sur la colonne
c’arrête pas mal de petites choses à
faire il y a pas de tourner les Noirs
ils doivent faire très attention à
chaque coup qui est dame bettera faut
que j'ai cinq frères 4 donc tu te payes
changer le cavalier
et
même ici dame dessin qui est pas débile
avec prise et qu'elle va laisser 4 je
peux vraiment taper sur des 6 même si
des pions doublés bon là maintenant on
va se donner la colonne eux donc on veut
pas
que c'est un coup qui qu'on peut avoir
même Damas 2 vous voyez même d'Amadou
qui a ridicule mais l'idée c'est pour
passer le cavalier essayez de bah
regarde j'ai dit
est-ce que je suis pas un génie s'il
vous plaît
par contre oui c'est c'était
en fait
j'imagine que il voulait pas que les
Noirs vous descente parce que il aurait
pu jouer C4 il y a trois coups avec la
dame en 4 à l'époque et juste c'est
autoriser 5 ou 5 ou un truc comme ça et
bon ben voilà il a pas envie quoi
F4 dans la merde j'aime bien mettre des
seins
maintenant qui est plutôt le 5 c'est
vrai qu'elle va être mieux en décembre
oui près d'âme des cinq j'imagine qu'il
est noir voudront les changer il va te
faire de la musique ou quoi ouais mais
dans ce cas là
parce que je voulais c'est à dire que si
je fais ça ça moi je me pose mon
cavalier il est hyper stable il a un
délogeable et ce pion
on va aller se cacher là-bas pour
défendre ouais mais bon
comparé juste les les foules les
cavaliers
l'impression que je vais te raser hein
et après avoir si on parce que je vais
changer
en fait je pense que je peux même manger
je vais peut-être un peu passer qui peut
je sais pas j'ai l'impression vraiment
que que je peux ah bah de toute façon
pour avoir la structure que tu veux moi
non pas prise
c'est ça
j'ai quelque part
avoir
mais en tout cas j'aime beaucoup la
pause des blancs c'est vraiment une
position de travail ou vraiment
[Musique]
il y a plein de choses à faire plein de
choses à faire
les noirs sont en souffrance avec ce
mauvais coup quoi mais bon
il peut y avoir des cas de figure où les
Noirs donnent un pion pour s'activer et
ça peut aussi suffire
il a 3 minutes d'avance à la pendule
une potion plus sympa donc
il a ses chances
une bonne position en fait c'est arrivé
à obtenir un langage conséquent
ça suffit quoi même si après autant que
tu rattrapes
d'avoir beaucoup d'avance au temps c'est
pas mal c'est pas mal de quand même
simplifier
ok considère que des 5 sera jamais du
coup jamais une menace peut-être
donc là il y a plein d'idées il y a du
B4 dans l'air
pas tout de suite mais un jour
pour ça j'ai quatre mais bon
l'espace là-bas
en PLS
ouais 5 G5 et tu peux dire au revoir à
ton fou quasiment faudra faire descendre
mais bon ça structure il y a en plus il
y a des réseaux de maths
et ouais c'est c'est très moche il a pas
joué FC
comme ça et même faire
donc à chaque fois B3 il y aura plus de
problème là-dessus et puis on peut
doubler on peut l'enlever 3 on peut pas
me faire une session on veut on verra
alors
du D5 de jouets et a priori l'ordi
n'aime pas je vois qu'il met un point
d'interrogation
alors pourquoi ça on ne le sait pas
peut-être justement
bien ça même pas mal
il a mangé il fait toujours
pas mal aussi effectivement
tous les plans sont faibles tous et puis
c'est inévitable tu peux pas faire
tomber 5 ouais
bah écoute ça je crois que ça va pas
traîner longtemps en fait je pense que
ça va être très vite gagné pour les
blancs en fait
position de base trop dur à gérer tout
F5 la prise prise tombée
jours je veux dire c'est ça bon là il y
a le foussette donc il va lire un fuite
il va faire un truc avant ou j'ai faim
j'ai 5 et maintenant
belle finale c'est la partie et tomber 3
j'ai ça pour l'instant il est très
propre
elle est bien loin parce que là je peux
le faire même à 5 ça va les prendre les
deux hein mais sur A5
en plus
[Musique]
bon dernière tentative enfin qui n'est
pas une mais tu peux faire [__]
il s'en fout
non je m'en fous
ça a l'air ça a l'air quasiment terminé
je crois que c'est terminé juste bon tu
peux toujours entendre des pièges ici ou
là et on sait jamais mais
bon
il prend d'accord
c'est vrai qu'en fait tu as peut-être
casser la tête là c'est comme si tu as
un pion de plus vu que le pion c'est 5
il est là mais bon
il avance pas contrairement au purin
donc c'est pas con ce qu'il fait encore
plus fort en plus
c'est une menace parce que bah presque
elle va les prendre le montant il est
quasiment inarrêtable on n'a jamais
froid
qui empêche éventuellement tu peux déjà
comme ça
pire c'est que ça ressort genre ça c'est
tu fais un coup je fais ça je me la
semaine échec suivi de ton B7 qui avait
changé et mon pion qui va aller à Dame
après
non mais il y a rien à faire c'est juste
abandonnable déjà comme position ouais
on le voit dans son
body language
il essaie
bon au final c'était le choix de
Forest d'avoir
mais
[Musique]
non mais il a fait une partie sur
demande avec les Blancs et là pour le
coup c'est classe
qui a essayé de faire des cinq quand il
a pu pour se libérer mais juste ça
allait pas fallait accepter de souffrir
et peut-être perdre à long terme mais tu
as tellement vide
pas du tout comment il peut s'en sortir
il y a pas de quoi en fait non mais il y
a rien à faire là
un truc comme ça je sais pas
c'est ça
aussi et puis toute façon qui est ici
non
et perdu peut-être un moment ici serait
un coup mais bon quand on finale et que
tu vas devoir partir du tournoi tu as
pas envie d'abandonner tu vas tenter un
truc
il a raison il faut il faut 500 on va on
n'a jamais gagné en avoir dedans mais
là je suis pas très optimiste pour lui
surtout qu'en plus il y en a quasiment 9
minutes encore donc il va même pas tu
vois un monde panique ou tu n'as même
pas des trucs compliqués à calculer
c'est
bel exemple de qui avait les comptes
fous ouais bah super par exemple si par
exemple de cavalier dominateur sur le
fou mauvais fou il fait ce qu'on avait
dit enfin ce qu'on a posé
mais là on va pas donc là il y a plutôt
B8
aussi éventuellement moi
mais au pire tu calcules pas quoi
ça gagne les yeux fermés ça et j'ai 4
par exemple et voilà qui fait une
barrière entre lui et le fou et son pion
F5 malheureusement pourra monter soit
aider son pion passer bon de toute façon
donc il y a trop de problèmes il y a 6
surveille il y a déjà surveiller il y a
le droit et dès que le feu rouge j'ai
encore ça ça
ben non c'est juste c'est juste perdu
c'est la partie arrive
c'est pas mal aussi
à faire et noir bouge plus la tour en 7
va aller fixer
et le fou bouge pas à cause de
casque
alors ouais
parce que
8 je te fais tourrage switch je te force
à les recettes là je te prends le fou et
fourchettes ouais c'est marrant et en
fait à chaque fois il y a un truc il y a
une fourchette partout tout le temps
quoi
il a passé
la position est perdue il pourrait
abandonner mais c'est normal de pas
abandonner ici hein certains la partie
du match
il faut tenter et puis une déconnexion
peut toujours arriver
[Musique]
par exemple
tout gagne même pour apprendre
tout
ta caméra qui est parti encore bon c'est
quoi c'est la dernière aujourd'hui
et abondant abandon de la part de ventes
forest
rapidement si vous voulez la partie
juste
complètement complètement rasé elle a
changé de bonne pièce donc là vous voyez
il a changé le fou contre le cavalier
pour avoir les pions sur la couleur du
fond noir et la changer les fous ici et
ensuite les cavaliers et en échange tous
ces pièces là et bien il se retrouve
avec un bon cavalier potentiel contre un
fou qui va être derrière ce pion
et au final on va regarder il a pris là
la dame la tour et maintenant il a mis
le cavalier ici il a mis le filtre très
joli Damas 2 que j'ai eu un peu de
chance de trouver
et au final ben écoute la position en
fait elles sont toutes seules
la position c'est c'est incroyable de
gagner avec autant de facilité quoi une
partie d'échec c'est ouf quoi donc en
tout cas surtout que en face ça joue
quoi en fait ah oui en face c'est 2700 €
quoi c'est juste monstrueux quoi alors
on va vous montrer le petit bracket
avant de vous laisser
alors le bracket il est là donc on a
maintenant vous voyez carvana qui vient
de gagner la finale des losers donc
demain à partir de 17h on va être de
nouveau sur la chaîne avec Fab pour vous
commenter en direct le grand match
retour je dis retour parce que vous
voyez que Carolin
ils ont déjà joué en semi-finale des
gagnants et c'est abdouk avait gagné
deux et demi à 1 et demi donc là il se
rejoue pour la grande finale donc c'est
quatre parties de 15 + 3 en cas de match
nul il y aura un armage et donc bien sûr
et en cas de victoire de abzotorov
tournoi sera terminé et Abdou sera sacré
vainqueur de cette édition et si karena
par contre gagne le match il y aura un
match retour encore une fois parce que
chaque joueur a droit à un joker à une
vie et donc en fait pour que Cavana
gagne le tournoi il faut qu'il gagne
les deux sets face à
un gros challenge on verra s'il y arrive
ou quoi prenons Abdou favori sur ce qui
montre depuis le début mais là
franchement aujourd'hui Fabiano a bien
joué il était il était franchement
incréable
c'était beau à voir donc donc voilà bah
écoute demain 17h pour la grande finale
entre Abdou et karwana merci à tous
d'avoir suivi du coup le stream merci à
toi beaucoup Fab de m'avoir accompagné
aujourd'hui
donc j'aimerais faire un petit raid
avant